there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey you guys happy wednesday yep i just
noticed that it was 4 20 which i'm sure
will make pot smokers very excited
isn't it like the pot smoking holiday or
whatever yeah uh camp guy says the new
john wayne gacy documentary on netflix
is pretty good so far i'm gonna have to
like uh i'm gonna have to watch that i
didn't check netflix in a
in a while i'm not really sure like what
new [ __ ] they've added i put new um
shades up in here new blinds new blinds
they don't have slats it's just it's a
single one that comes down and it's it's
blackout
so that sun's blazing over there man on
the other side of that and it's nice and
cool and dark in here i'm going to
replace this whole i'm going to place
every one of them in this house with
that
because yeah it's nice so much easier on
the air conditioner that air conditioner
is not hardly kicking on now
well and another thing too is that i
like the way the new blinds don't have
all those strings and [ __ ] like that
hanging down you know
i don't like i don't want pokey getting
like tangled in yeah [ __ ] it's gonna be
good so i'm gonna get that hooked up man
some weird [ __ ] happened with this
[ __ ] house
out of the blue i get a let i didn't say
anything about it because i didn't have
all the information
get a letter
from the insurance company saying we're
dropping your insurance because your
roof isn't up to spec and you guys
didn't respond and blah blah blah
so i called the damn
mortgage holder
mortgage company
and and i said what the [ __ ] is this man
this house passed an inspection and blah
blah blah that's like three inspections
and they're like what the [ __ ] this is
we don't know what's up with that
and
turns out
the insurance companies in this area
they're all owned by vanguard and
blackrock and they're [ __ ] squeezing
everybody if your
roof is older than 10 years they want
you to replace your [ __ ] roof
shingles
all right whether
they even want the same thing these
people have these big tile roofs that
have 50-year guarantees on them
they want them [ __ ] done so there's
gonna they're gonna be some there's
gonna be some kind of fight about it but
during that inspection it's that said
that this hat that this roof had at
least three good years in it
so anyway mortgage company says man
don't worry about that [ __ ] [ __ ] um
worst case thing that could happen is
that the bank will give you
their own insurance
it's the same thing it's just that it
doesn't doesn't insure anything inside
your house and it doesn't uh the rates
not may not be as as well but the but
then the insurance company is saying
well we might we're gonna we're gonna
reconsider we're gonna give you an
extension
uh maybe we'll give you this extension
because we just moved here
yeah like just a few months ago was it
like six months ago yeah september or
october and it went it and and that
inspection only happened about a month
ago two months ago and they said no
you're good to go so they're backing up
on their own
this is how they do an insurance company
is a company that
will you pay them every month and then
they ride the risk that something will
happen and they lose
but then they try to tweak the laws so
they make you take all the risks
yeah that's something
when you need our insurance and you have
to [ __ ] fix your house so there's no
risk to us
that's not insurance yeah because they
have all these like loopholes it's like
oh well that happened like this way so
that means we don't have to pay for it
medical insurance is the same way yeah
you know oh well maybe that was a
pre-existing condition so we're not
going to cover that sorry
so we got to get the governor man
[ __ ] on that [ __ ]
[ __ ] there's a lot of [ __ ] that
[ __ ] those those two particular
companies are doing waging war on
[ __ ] mankind
trying to shut down trying to kill all
the chickens they're trying to kill all
the cows so you buy their friends bill
gates [ __ ] synthetic chicken in his
synthetic cows
grandparents says big news gramphers hit
ten thousand dollars playing the
michigan lottery today oh holy [ __ ] did
you really damn damn that's lucky damn
congratulations and you probably get
what half of it after taxes you'll
probably get half well most of them i
think most kind of lotteries have well
you can either take like a lesser thing
now with the tax already taken out um or
you can take like ticketed installments
which you'll get the whole amount but
it's not like all at once yeah but i
think they they the the taxes
i think they're 50 on winnings
it depends on what it is it depends on
the amount um
and a lot of other things because i've
heard of like lottery winners that won
like big lotteries and it wasn't fifty
percent at the beginning graham says
he'll probably get seven grand after
taxes yeah that's about what i thought i
was gonna say seven or eight grand
which you know [ __ ] man there's nothing
to sneeze at murder harness says his
insurance pays for his viagra because of
his prostate
[Laughter]
man i wouldn't think you needed them
dick pills man not after [ __ ] all
that testosterone you're injecting you
probably needed dick pills although i
heard that some guys who are on hrt and
steroids
will take viagra on top of that they say
you [ __ ] get bigger faster
there's something having to do with the
blood vessels
weird huh yeah because some guys were
being issued that like on a standard
hrt
package
the doctor is throwing in dick pills
man i [ __ ] got hold of one of them
dick pills one time man had two i
remember jenny yeah wore jenny out
i think it was like a sample it wasn't
it wasn't viable i think it was seattle
somebody gave it to me that's right it
came in a damn box with two yeah it was
like a sample like yeah and that just
sat around for years and years and this
is how i'm traveling in [ __ ] pills
yeah we kind of forgot yeah
[Laughter]
you could like
you can [ __ ] anything [ __ ] a damn tire
car coming at you you're trying to [ __ ]
the car
well you're probably lucky you didn't
have the erection lasting more than four
hours [ __ ] it's like for [ __ ] hours
man and you're like
the refractory period you know [ __ ]
there's like seconds
busting that now like a couple seconds
later i'm ready to go again
i need to get some of that [ __ ]
yeah they kind of think of it man i need
to get some of that maybe you got that
[ __ ] down in mexico
he's hitting around now i'm thinking
about it
that'd be yeah that [ __ ] was pretty good
it was yeah it was it was like i said
that was cialis it wasn't right but i
think it's the same [ __ ] isn't it
probably yeah it's the same thing
they should have they should have uh
generic ones by now
you would think i know that uh
china and north korea were making cheat
with making knockoffs of it it says i
understand why like why can't you buy
that [ __ ] over the counter or can you i
don't know anything i have
no
no the doctors want their cut
i know but then it's weird because there
are some things that you absolutely can
buy over the counter that you think you
wouldn't be able to i don't know it's
just like i don't know it's just like a
whole [ __ ] cluster box that [ __ ] is a
[ __ ] uh hell of a
hell of a [ __ ] recreational drug
though it is yeah yeah
murder hornet says i just use them for
mexico and then tammy said tammy said
i'd love to see a prescription that says
for boner
well you have to pretend it's like a
medical issue it's it's erectile
dysfunction that sounds better than
saying it's kind of psychological too
well yeah i'm sure that there's like
some aspect of placebo effect and then
there's kind of like a um that [ __ ] was
like uh
i wouldn't want to wouldn't say it was
like cocaine
it's not like testosterone it but it has
a feel to it
you know it's not like it did for me
yeah it felt like a drug kind of
like an aphrodisiac
grantham said i'd rather not quick and
go to sleep than have a four-hour time
yeah
yeah yeah i know that really
once you get to a certain age it's just
kind of like okay
take cialis
sust 350 and tren
and fight
tom you're gonna you're gonna
[Laughter]
you're just i don't know what you're
going to do i don't know yeah you're
just going gonna blow up one of these
days it's gonna be all right you think
it's gonna be right
maybe until it's until it's not i'm old
you're not that old no yeah i'm [ __ ]
it's it's all [ __ ]
all coming together
it's all coming together all coming it's
all coming together yeah i'm going along
schedule [ __ ]
building back man building back better
[ __ ] in a couple years i look good
those look really good
[ __ ]
i think in the next six months i'm gonna
[ __ ] drop about another 10 pounds of
fat
maybe i'm not sure i have 10 pounds on
me but probably huh
i don't know it's like you don't really
you don't really seem to have much fat
on you to be fair i mean well i got some
right here still
but that might be the only area to be
honest i mean your legs are small like
your belly isn't that big like your butt
is small yeah so there's not much but
there's about another i think there's
well there's also fat inside the muscle
tissue itself well i'm just talking
about like you know
visible fat there's probably 10 pounds
there
so if i had to lose five i'd probably be
about
probably about eight percent body fat if
i lost five pounds
that'd look good i did six packs of [ __ ]
six packs not natural
six packs just for drug addicts and
[ __ ] dudes that are [ __ ] juicing
i [ __ ] saw a show on it
they [ __ ] dude tracked it down
[ __ ] by individual dude with all
these [ __ ] six man had to go nope
nope nope drug addict drug addict
[ __ ] juice and juice and juice and it
it's it's
because not even young guys that really
work out unless they're gifted
genetically even they don't really have
them
you know what i mean yeah not even a
[ __ ] 17 18 year old really has them
usually
that
it's just when they [ __ ] go on juice
they get they start getting
yeah
it's it's
not natural
speaking of
testosterone yeah the show tonight is
road rage yep
it's all interrelated
it definitely is in a room it definitely
is
i mean
um i had like i have like four or five
cases some of them are short
uh so we'll kind of get into like
talking about that but
i don't know it's here's an interesting
statistic that i found though
um
like a bunch of different studies since
we're talking about testosterone
it says a number of studies have found
that individuals with road rage are
predominantly young the average age is
33 no surprise there
and 96.6
male 1
now i'm not saying i'm not saying that
women don't do it too because i've seen
like i was watching a couple
documentaries earlier and they had like
some pretty egregious like ones of women
doing it too
although
the women don't usually end up killing
people you know what i mean there was
one where she kind of like caused an
accident and [ __ ] like that but
um
there's been one and actually there was
when i was doing the uh the research for
this i found a case that happened in
orlando just yesterday matter of fact uh
so we'll talk about that in a little bit
too but
problem uh florida is actually i don't
know about i mean as far as like the
latest uh statistics go florida is
actually uh number one in road rage
incidents which uh probably shouldn't
surprise anyone
because everyone well and everyone's
like [ __ ] super aggro yeah down here
uh drugs
drugs dude we'd be driving and [ __ ]
some dude
take off on
you're going 70 and he's past you at 120
and he'll run right into the back end of
the traffic jam and try to get around it
in the downtown area or you know i mean
when you well that happens that's right
that's why i hate driving on this
brazilian i hate it like that's a
brazilian only a brazilian drives that
way they think that they're racist well
i don't know about that i've seen i've
lived here my whole entire life and i've
seen people driving like that all the
time zillions have been here they're
your whole damn entire life when i was
you know some of them are white dudes
i've seen white dudes driving like that
well you know what i mean i
fit right in with a lot of brazilians
you know because you because you also
drive like that no you don't no i don't
drive but i i didn't even drive like
that in brazil yeah when i was driving
but no they're [ __ ] they all think
they're nelson pk man that they all
think they're race car drivers
um can once you turn that up a little
bit maybe get a little bit more that's
as bright as it goes as bright as it
goes yeah that's the problem no i need
to do we need to put something white
there because now that that now that
that light is [ __ ] cut out of the mix
we can perfect this lighting setup yeah
you know trying to get us some more soft
power how do we look guys on your uh on
your screen do we look fuzzy or
can you
because the way it was before a lot of
times was just really unflattering with
the angle of the light coming in through
the back of the sideways and [ __ ] make
it look like the goddamn mummy
trying to get a a good
um either make you look like [ __ ] old
crinkled up paper or fat or something
you know what i mean so we gotta try to
get some flattery light
up in here now that we have the
light situation under total control now
yeah i mean like i said i might be
better look at that [ __ ]
yeah i know yeah
uh tammy said looks good here
thank you zach
uh speaking of the body i took a small
drag from a joint the other day and the
new job i'm applying to my drug test so
i'm freaking out yeah i'm not actually
sure how
well how well how long in between is it
gonna be like before the drug test and
like when i don't know i don't know how
how much of a joint you would have had
to smoke for it to pick it up
i used to [ __ ] hate that man drug
test like unless i turn up to the
[ __ ]
job like whacked out i can't do my job
then mind your own damn business you
know what i mean yeah what the hell
would they need that for i can
understand if you're operating heavy
equipment over here yeah
or fly in a plane or some [ __ ] like that
yeah where people are gonna die if you
don't do it right but yeah it's like who
the [ __ ] cares if i'm high god damn it
as long as you're getting the work done
probably has something to do with their
insurance yeah that's exactly what it's
to do with because they're like hey we
don't want a bunch of druggies like
slasher fred says some drivers don't
realize the seriousness of driving yeah
a lot of them don't well it's just
something that people do every day and
you just get used to it and
you know you very rarely stop to think
that oh i'm driving around this two-ton
piece of machinery that could like
[ __ ] obliterate a person see me and
granters
we came from a generation of real men
back when we were going to high school
and whatever trenton high when we went
through the damn driver's education
program they showed us a video of all
them [ __ ] dead bodies they pull out
of the cars the damn [ __ ] jaw hanging
off the dude i saw those two does that
make me also a real man yeah yeah it
makes you a real man too but just
in generation x and before
they horrified you
they let you know that
you get killed driving these things if
you [ __ ] you know
if you [ __ ] hit something and it
doesn't take much speed you can get
killed at [ __ ] 35 mile an hour impact
yep kill you deader than [ __ ]
that's why it upsets me i see these
[ __ ] bikers at the [ __ ] bar
because there's there's no you don't
have to wear a helmet in florida you
just need glasses and a lot of these
[ __ ] fat old dudes you know what i
mean being all cool on their harleys and
[ __ ] they can't ride really
you know they can ride around on a
harley but they don't really have good
at it in stakes they haven't been riding
that long
and
harley can still [ __ ] cash or can
write a check that that [ __ ]
can't cash
uh something can happen faster than his
reaction time
and he comes off that bike
you don't realize that coming off at 25
miles an hour and your head hits that
[ __ ] concrete that's equivalent to
the [ __ ] strike with a baseball bat
yep
good
yeah and 25 is like nothing it seems
like when you're driving it seems like
nothing i peeled one dude off the
[ __ ] intersection his bike was up in
the des this is remember that a couple
years back
and he was just this one of them [ __ ]
harley dudes
he had a helmet on though but he had a
little skull cap helmet it just covered
the very top of his head which is better
than nothing but it looks like that damn
hat from fred flintstone with just the
turtle
you remember that turtle [ __ ] hat and
dude on the brontosaurus
[Laughter]
and he was just face down in a road i go
through i weave through all the [ __ ]
cars to get into the accident scene
because i was on my bike to get up in
the accident scene jump off and
everybody don't know what to do what do
i do you know what i mean [ __ ] people
he's face down going
[Music]
head injury frontal head injury just
fighting himself and [ __ ] rolled him
over and just said just keep him on his
back elevate his feet
you know [ __ ]
it sounds funny but [ __ ] unbuckled
his [ __ ] pants you know because he
had a big old [ __ ] belly
and just trying to keep his circulation
going yeah you know that's not funny
that's a lot of people like man you
don't understand it said i said i
[ __ ] i know first aid [ __ ] loose
and all this [ __ ] yeah
and then it just [ __ ] went up and
[ __ ] looked at his bike in the damn
[ __ ]
flower bed and the entrance way to that
damn thing and around that time the cops
showed up and i said you guys got it
under control said that's a frontal head
injury man he's [ __ ]
and it says yeah yeah and then i left
they were they [ __ ] but
didn't have a real helmet on
and he wasn't going that fast yeah the
witnesses said he wasn't going that fast
at all about 45
but he wasn't wearing a full face helmet
just that little damn skull cap that
didn't have any impact
absorption you know you just [ __ ] he
hit the side
so
these [ __ ] driving this [ __ ]
today driving around i think they came
from first of all i don't think there's
much with driver's ed courses in the
united states anymore they definitely
don't terrorize them like they did our
generation just show them a bunch of
dead bodies show them what [ __ ]
impact looks like about how little of an
impact it takes to turn your brains to
mush
don't take much
and uh
what it's like hitting the damn steering
column
you know if you didn't have a seat belt
on
and back in the day they didn't have
[ __ ] um
airbags
and uh the steering columns didn't bend
much
that used to be that people got killed
just by having a steering column shoved
through their chest my grandmother's uh
brother died like that when he was 17.
yeah
um he hit a tree and the steering column
went right through his chest and impaled
him yeah yep
or you're thrown up over it into the
steering column and the passenger goes
up into the [ __ ] windshield and
they're just mashed up against the
inside of the windshield
then they bounce back in they don't come
out the windshield but just
that sometimes kills them just hitting
the windshield
crush your head
yeah and i mean the thing about it is
like cars nowadays are much much safer
than they used to be back in the old
days
but
that a car can only do so much but yeah
exactly i only do so much and if you're
driving like an [ __ ] yeah
and the thing about it is like um you
know like tammy was saying earlier that
she drives for a living and a lot of
people drive like idiots and stupid they
do i mean people do stupid [ __ ] they're
on their [ __ ] phones they're doing
dumb ass that they're not paying
attention and
you know and i can understand like why
that makes people mad
but
the problem being that like even if you
see like i was watching this documentary
earlier right and there's this guy and
he's a motorcyclist i think he's in
denver
and he's kind of
i don't know if he's around anymore
because i don't know how old this
documentary was but he's kind of like
dubbed himself this kind of like rude
avenger where he goes around on his
motorcycle and if he sees people doing
dumb [ __ ] like on the road like they're
on their phone or whatever he'll like
excoriate them about it but i'm like
dude
i i don't one it's like that seems like
a really douchy thing to do and two it's
like that
is exactly what they tell you not to do
to like avoid road rage they said look
it's like the problem is you see
somebody doing some dumb [ __ ] they're
like just don't engage
because a lot of times if you call out
that person like what the [ __ ] well like
what are you doing and then they'll turn
on you you don't know if that person's
armed you don't know if that person's
insane or they just got out of jail or
something like that they're always just
kind of like look if they're doing dumb
[ __ ] just get the [ __ ] away from them
and go home it's like don't worry about
it because it's not worth getting
[ __ ] killed over because some dumb
[ __ ] is like doing stupid [ __ ] on the
road you know what i'm saying i mean
obviously unless they're doing something
really dangerous in which case still
don't engage them to call the cops you
know what i mean tennis doesn't even
teach you they didn't even teach kids
how to change a tire anymore they're not
a chance tired that was that was what
you learned that in driver's ed they
didn't teach me that in driver's ed my
dad my dad taught me you know but i
don't remember i knew before but i don't
remember grandpa's did they teach us how
to change a tire i think they did i
think they did i don't think they taught
us that in drivers i could be wrong it
was a long time ago our driver's ed's
course was before school that [ __ ] went
on it seemed like for weeks man had i
had to get up when it was still dark and
waiting outside it was dark
you know i mean [ __ ] five o'clock in
the morning
ours was just a regular class yeah it
was a classmate started before school no
ours is just like a regular class like
you would take the day and it was it was
like a nine week class it was like one
semester or maybe two semesters yeah it
seemed to take forever i think it was
nine weeks we were eventually driving
before school and [ __ ]
yeah that's pretty cool then we got our
learner's permit
at school i think we got the driver's
license later
we got deleted yeah well yeah because
you have to get the drive well that's
how it was back then like you get the
learner's permit well you had to get the
learner's permit before you even took
the class because or you had to take the
written test in the class then you get
your learner's permit then they would
let you out on the range and drive
around and then at the end of the
semester
then you went to
you know the place in your county or
whatever and took the driving test and
got your actual driver's license
zach says i'm 25 and still and thank you
by the way i'm 25 and still working on
getting my license sadly but i kind of
don't trust myself to be a good driver
as much as i don't trust others yeah i
get that i mean i didn't get miles under
you i didn't really learn to drive like
i took driver's ed but i didn't really
drive but then i didn't have any money
to have a car so i didn't really start
driving until i was in my mid-20s you
know what i mean
um
but
i honestly really don't like to drive uh
i don't mind driving if there's nobody
else on the road
but if there's other people around yeah
i don't like it i don't like it i was
driving in my teens
yeah well i was too but i didn't really
because i didn't have a money for a car
i just didn't drive so i was always like
you know taking the bus or sponging off
until i got you know older got a job and
got money to get my own car and then i
took more lessons because i was like
wanted to make sure i was doing it right
but i got to get some we just got to get
some miles under your wheels zach
i mean it was easy you just got it
well it was easy for me because it
became second nature you just got to
drive a lot
just keep driving it'll become second
nature and the thing about it too is
that the driving test in the u.s at
least in most parts of the u.s is super
easy compared to europe oh yeah where
europe they don't teach you for free you
got to pay for lessons and two the test
is super hard like you [ __ ] up one thing
fail you got to start over yeah they
pretended like it's like an airplane
well they they also don't have a lot of
automatics over there like you can buy
an automatic but everything is uh manual
transmission that's easy too though
and the roads i have to say like when i
first went over there like to the uk i
was like man these roads are so [ __ ]
small they're really really small and
really really twisty and you have to be
like really good at like maneuvering
around everything like all at all times
because there's i mean over here we have
big wide
open roads and stuff they don't really
have that so much over there so you
really have to like have your [ __ ]
together i've been paying attention i've
owned both automatics and
my first car was a man it was a manual
and
my first car was a in brazil and it was
a
it was a what we call a fusca which is a
volkswagen bug a brazilian made
volkswagen bug
and it was a
manual
but i also had a toyota sr5 5 speed back
in the 80s that was a [ __ ] fun little
car
fast little thing you know for a little
economy car a little corolla
and uh the europeans man they [ __ ]
love those standards for some reason i
mean that's just what they're used to
you can get automatics over there but
most people are just used to i mean they
learned on a manual they're used to
driving a manual there's a lot of like i
said there's a lot of in and out traffic
hills [ __ ] like that so they're just
like used to driving them yeah there's
absolutely no automatics i kind of feel
like they almost feel like it's cheating
yeah
there's there's no reason for a standard
in the united states there's no
advantage to it matter of fact it's just
a pain in the ass yeah because the roads
here are built
they're very [ __ ] straight
and uh boring by the european standards
and not they're wide they're not
congested
and it's when you're in town it's just
stop and go slow
traffic most of it
and
all that [ __ ] clutching and [ __ ]
shifting they're just painting the ass
you could be sitting there eating
in an automatic
i mean so yeah you could be eating with
one hand of driving and driving this
yeah when i was when i was in boston i
was dating a german girl and she was
goofing on me because my [ __ ] car was
an automatic but then when she would
ride around with me for a while she goes
yeah i see why you have automatics now
there's no reason for a standard like no
yeah it's the road is the road situation
or are totally different right and then
there's uh then they'll counter goes yes
but the standards are more uh uh
reliable no they're not they're not at
all and automatic transmissions the new
ones or the ones that they've had
anything past the late 80s will run
forever
damn near forever especially the
american ones
because
the engine's only putting out 150 140 or
150 horsepower but the transmission
would be rated to [ __ ] handle like
250 300 horsepower so just very over
built [ __ ] automatics and there's
just
very little that can go wrong in them
i've had some of those [ __ ] american
cars to where
the the [ __ ] car has a hundred and
something thousand miles on it and it's
that same transmission and you not even
really know you don't even really know
if the transmission oil's ever been
changed
which is ridiculous when you think about
it
but that's just the life of a lot of
those cars
they're like that probably just added
transmission fluid
but some of that [ __ ] that i've had i
don't think was ever changed
it doesn't matter
not really
yeah i mean
like i said my first car was a manual
yeah and
man that [ __ ] was a pain in the ass
manual said the clutch plates have to be
replaced a lot there's a lot of blocks
well and that's what ended up happening
like i had it for a year or two it was
used when i got it obviously because i
didn't have a lot of money but yeah the
clutch went and they're like well uh we
could replace this whole thing but it's
gonna cost more than the cars worth yeah
so
yeah they're just
so i
the american roads beat them up pretty
bad american driving beats them up
and you know i think europe likes them
because they don't drive that much you
know
there's nowhere to go they don't they
don't
you know for them an hour drive was like
well that's a long way not an hour's
nothing here
well in europe in an hour you could be
in another country yeah yeah there's
more to go
[ __ ] here in florida you're still in
[ __ ] florida yeah
after several hours yeah it takes an
hour to go from here to the club and we
do it
you know
and don't pass anything on the way there
yeah because it's all kind of i mean it
doesn't take quite an hour it's probably
like 45 45 minutes something like that
yeah
uh hey our friend david parker is here
hey dude what's up okay what's up how
are you doing all right we're getting
sidetracked
well i mean we're talking about cars
still yeah
and we're still in the first hour right
uh he says took driver's ed during the
summer when i was 15 years old our
teacher taught us how to change a tire
okay okay on my 16th birthday walked in
and got my driver's license without a
test that's right yeah they did that at
our school too like i said nine weeks
they gave you the class and you could
actually you could go to the place and
take the test yeah or you could opt to
take the test at the school and then
they would give you a voucher and then
and then you would just go and like pick
it up you got a permit just by by
completing the test and a written test
no no no we gotta just by completing the
school test
remember there's a final test at the end
of the school thing you got a permit
and
but it was like a day permit you can
only drive during the day learners
permit but yeah you get well that's what
i was saying it didn't come from the dmv
no the the school sent it to there and
it came from and the dmv sent to us i
think the learner's permit yeah i had to
go before i took the class
this is michigan though i had to go
before i took the class and the
learner's permit they'll give it to you
if you just take a written test you
didn't have to take the driving test i
was 15. yeah and you could just you need
it right
no i won't no because i went to the
place and took it and then i took the
class i think i i don't know where
grandparents went but i think we took
that learner's permit test at school i
think that was like the final exam type
of deal
because i remember it just showing up in
the damn
mailbox and then and you had to have
that learner's permit and you could only
drive
you could only drive during the day on
the weekend on the weekday and then you
could drive at night on the weekends
i think ours you could drive during the
day you could drive at night if you had
a job at night
or if there was an older licensed driver
somebody over 21 or 25 in the car with
you then i remember driving at night and
it was legal on the weekends
uh but you could go to yeah yeah i don't
remember if it maybe it was i can't
really remember it was a long time ago
but i know if you had a job at night
because a lot of kids had you know they
worked at mcdonald's or whatever after
school and they could drive at night
you had to have that for several months
and then you had to go down to the dmv
and like you said i think they just gave
you a driver's license you just took a
picture and they gave you the driver's
license
yeah i don't think there was even any
test
because you already took the test it's
cool yeah yeah you took the test at
school yeah you could do like we had
that at the end of the semester you
could take the class you could take the
test like the driving test at school
yeah or if you wanted to you could go to
the dmv and take it yeah i took mine at
i actually ended up taking mine at the
dmv in orange city i don't remember why
that happened
but yeah so i didn't take it at school i
took it at the dmv at orange city
and i only i only missed one point
i didn't stop
i didn't stop like far enough behind the
stop sign white line and they dinged me
a point for that but that's all i got
off
but yeah
uh yeah written test for learner's
permit dmv yeah because you had to have
that before
you were allowed to drive in the class
like in the school class so you had to
have that first
like they would do like book work for
the first week or two like teaching you
all the rules and the signs and all that
kind of crap yeah yeah they would do
that yeah we didn't have any road rage
issues there though
i kind of i don't know it just seems
like you can drive that [ __ ] it was easy
i mean obviously kind of like
road rage
as far as they can determine it's
actually gotten a lot worse
in the last decade
uh road rate it's not so much road rage
like all the time but like road rage
related deaths and as in people dying as
a result of it uh increase of 500
percent
since 2012 last decade kevin's saying
you look beautiful jenny oh thank you
she looks great [ __ ] with long hair
i'm wearing i'm wearing tom's dancing
[Laughter]
it looks great with long hair parted in
the middle
well i'm trying to grow my actual hair
back to that it's just kind of like it's
taking a long time yeah it's flattering
to her face to have that part in the
middle
i was going to put the blue wig on but
then i was like oh wait i have a red
necklace on and it's just like and i
thought i was supposed to get my cool
like fake red nails today and i was
gonna wear those and so i was like well
i can't wear blue hair and red nails
because i have a thing about like color
coordination
but they didn't show up today
so
it was just it was all
this this wig though you really should
brush it more like every time you wear
it it was all puffy because it yeah it
was all like had rat's nest and i had to
like brush it it's cause i'm just drunk
grab it yeah that's what i mean and you
just see you don't take care of your
stuff man because i went in there it's
giving us more money thanks dad are you
really yeah i must be like i must be a
little
thank you zach
they say it got worse but did they say
why
i don't know i just kind of feel like
maybe i mean cities are more congested
maybe like people are just angrier like
about other things and are like taking
it out on other drivers i'm not really
entirely sure probably have to look at
what the case is what the average case
is like now yeah it might be drug
related
well don't be gang-related you don't
know
well the thing about it if to call it a
road rage related death you would think
that they would at least have to have
some kind of like witnesses or something
like that that could attest to it
actually being caused by road rage you
know what i mean and not just
like a drive-by or whatever so
i don't know i'm just saying it like i
said this doesn't say road rage as a
whole this says deaths related to road
rage have increased 500 in the last
decade uh cases involving guns
doubled between 2014 and 2016.
in 2016 uh it was 620
shootings
uh that were a result of
road rage incidents
so that's nice so between 2014 and 2016
136 people shot due to incidents of road
rage in the u.s
now the next statistics statistic i
found eight in ten americans are
involved in road rage behavior at least
once a year i'm imagining these are just
the ones that are admitting it because
these i'm guessing these aren't ones
that are necessarily
picked up by police but
because everybody
i've had road road rage you've had roach
everybody's done it like i've been
driving and being like what the [ __ ] is
this person i'm gonna follow this person
how i'm gonna beat their ass what the
[ __ ] are they even doing and you know i
kind of feel like most people have done
that right
um you've done that i've done that
what's that what it's like i said just
having road rage feelings
like well i had that a couple months
back remember when i wanted to jump out
the car and beat that dude's ass in
front of the house that's what i mean
everybody's had stuff like that i
haven't i haven't done it for a long
time yeah but
one thing i did and this was a long time
ago this was probably like 15 years ago
um
but i remember doing this and i'm really
not proud of it and i said some do that
[ __ ] though huh hormones well yeah
obviously yeah
but i'm not proud of this and it's like
um
you know i'm lucky that i didn't get
[ __ ] killed because i easily could
have
i was driving i don't remember where i
was driving from this was like i said
this is probably like
13 14 15 years ago something like that
i'm driving on
i think it was i-4
and this [ __ ]
truck i think it was a pickup truck and
they were just like riding my ass like
right like right on my [ __ ] bumper
and it was just making me so so mad i
must i was probably mad about something
else like that day too but i was just
like what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is this
dude doing oh my god he's like flick
he's [ __ ] pissing me off and he's
just like doing that doing that doing
that doing that and then like he's like
going like that and i'm just like oh
[ __ ] i'm just gonna [ __ ] i'm gonna
get you i'm gonna get you and so like he
goes over like the fast lane i was like
oh yeah i'm gonna follow you and i was
like i followed david david
oh okay bye
see you later thank you for dropping by
but i'm sorry so i start following this
dude because he like really made me mad
like all the [ __ ] that he was doing
and while i was following this dude i'm
like yeah how do you like it how do you
like it i'm gonna ride right up on your
ass how do you like it and i'm doing
that and then all of a sudden my tire
goes a little bit like off the lip of
i-4 like into the median
um and the car
spun out across three
lanes
yeah and i'm sitting there going [ __ ] me
no i did that oh you did that that was
like years ago okay
and had had other cars been coming on
the highway i'd have easily been dead
i'd have been t-boned yeah because the
car spun all the way across
and i was just kind of like and i
stopped on the side and i was just like
okay let's let's not do that again
let's let's just calm down
and was it you know because i
i kind of have a thing about i'm very
impatient i tend to get like you know
really angry about stuff like that
and
the older i get though i'm just kind of
like look it's not really worth it
because i easily could have been killed
had there been another car coming
that you know because i just like spun
out like that it could have tebowed me
and i could have been dead and i'm just
like all because i was trying to punish
that guy because he was like just kept
riding up on my ass and being a dick and
i was trying to like make him plays how
do you like it so i was trying to like
and the thing about people like that
they don't learn you can't teach them
like they're not going to feel bad so
it's like don't bother you know what i
mean it's really really not worth it
hornets hornet says he prefers those
manuals his first car was a manual
yeah manuals are good they're like a
motor it's like a motorcycle you know
their motorcycles are manuals
manual transmission is good that's what
you want in a sports car or a race car
in your average [ __ ]
street car here in the us or truck yeah
you want a [ __ ] automatic it's just
too much trouble it's like a yet another
thing to deal with right that you don't
have to deal with right like i said the
the roads here are just very wide and
very straight yeah at most places and
it's like it's really just a hassle that
you don't need and there you know some
of these [ __ ] vehicles have all kinds
of computer controlled
automatic transmissions that you could
put high performance modes in and
traction modes the trucks have amazing
[ __ ] automatic [ __ ] transmissions
that four-wheel drive settings and [ __ ]
that happen and you know
but you just
as long as [ __ ]
light weight and speed are not a
priority then automatic is the way you
want to go
if
speed agility
something like a race car or sports car
you want you want [ __ ] standard
that way you can downshift and do
[ __ ]
up shift in weird ways and
you know
[ __ ]
downshifting is [ __ ] pretty good in a
turn sometimes if you need a bunch of
traction just but you know it's just
that's only racing
you know it's not
yeah just going back and forth to work
or going to the store yeah you don't
need it for that it's just like i said
it's just another thing that you
i mean automatic is just so easy just
like one [ __ ] you know you can go
stop you can put that all that argument
to rest
if you just [ __ ] get a badass
electric like [ __ ]
top-line tesla four-wheel drive electric
pure [ __ ] torque there's no
transmission
uh but
as we all know
electric cars are not really ready for
prime time yet they're trying to force
that [ __ ] into prime time
for stupid reasons you know
electric is the way to go electric is
[ __ ] [ __ ] great
the problem is the batteries aren't
ready it takes a long time to charge
them they're expensive
and then you say well it's green it is
not green this is a fantasy all right
this is this is what
this is what oligarchs want you to think
because they've invested in that
technology they want you to buy from
them
you got to [ __ ] pull that lithium out
of the ground they do it with big
machines and they have to [ __ ] burn
more [ __ ] fuel
mining all that lithium then then that
lithium saves you when you turn it into
a battery it's easier to just go direct
just burn the oil make it a very
efficient burn and it cuts that out of
the loop
so uh yeah your car seems to be green it
isn't they [ __ ] the amount of fuel
burned to get that lithium the amount of
fuel burned to generate the dam
electricity at the power plant it
doesn't make sense it's it's really
inefficient
uh
from this from the green point of view
but they know you're dumb and that
you'll do whatever they say and they're
trying to make money
will it work out one day yeah
but not yet
you have to have a [ __ ] easy way to
get that power you have to have nuclear
power plants everywhere and they won't
put up with that
nuclear power plants
fusion
[ __ ] and
some kind of synthetically produced
lithium type [ __ ] that you can make so
you don't have to mine it
and [ __ ] really badass [ __ ]
charging times yeah you might be able to
get that to work out but not it's not
ready that's [ __ ] 50 years away
but um
the first cars were electric back in the
1800s and that's really the way to go
it's more powerful a lot more simple
cheaper
you don't have to you know there's no
transmission the motor and transmission
are the same thing electric motor
put one of them in each wheel four-wheel
drive
control it with a computer
good batteries
and you that system would be lighter and
more powerful eventually and just yeah
or if you get rid of the batteries and
put a fusion reactor in there that'd
really be good running steam power
making a generator
well that might be more complicated
anyway i'm fantasizing go ahead
fantasizing tila just showed up hey
y'all happy wednesday what's up baby
tired but trying to get a buzz from this
watered-down pale ale okay good luck
with you just sit up in here and just
get high with us and we're going to talk
about road rage we're going to talk
about
some ass holes behind [ __ ] behind
the wheels everybody knows about
[ __ ] behind the wheel
all the time the thing about i mean
there's [ __ ] everywhere like every
like i said you go to the [ __ ]
grocery store there's [ __ ] in the
line like bitching about how long the
lion takes [ __ ] like that
but there's something really insidious
about road rage in particular because
you don't see the person you just see
the other car
so it's much easier to like dehumanize
this other driver because you're not
really looking at him like you don't
really see him as a person it's just
kind of like you know what i mean you're
just mostly seeing the car and maybe
just like a little blur behind the
window or whatever so it's much easier
to
direct your rage against that because it
doesn't seem like a human to you you
know what i mean
tila says road rage is really nasty here
in the bay area san francisco
yeah i kind of feel like
i mean the last as far as i know i think
the last two or three years uh florida
has had the most
but
you know it's kind of high everywhere so
where was okay so eight and ten
americans are involved in road rage
behavior at least once a year not
necessarily resulting in death but
they're just talking about road rage in
general uh one in three collisions
involves road rage
uh i mentioned this earlier but the uh a
bunch of studies say that
everybody does road rage men women
i was going to say children children
children
like a little toddler behind the wheel
you're a [ __ ] yeah
that doesn't happen i hope but uh yeah
uh average age 33 uh
overwhelmingly male 96.6 male
according to most studies
um i found this really interesting i
guess like if you think about it for a
second um it's not really that weird
um but according to a couple studies
they've done people who
have a bunch of bumper stickers on their
cars or a bunch of like [ __ ] on their
cars you know not necessarily bumper
stickers just like a bunch of
personalization
uh are way more likely uh to have to do
road rage than a person that just has
like a generic-looking car
um and it doesn't matter if it's bumper
stickers it doesn't matter what the
bumper stickers say it just like matters
like the number of them or the number of
the [ __ ] that they have on the of the
amount of [ __ ] that they have on their
car that's personal personalization uh
is a greater predictor of road rage than
pretty much anything else depending on
it doesn't matter like how old the car
is what the maker model is or anything
like that it's usually how personalized
is this car that is the number one
predictor other than you know age and
gender
uh between 2014 2016 where i said like
uh you know
that the amount of road rage incidents
involving guns had doubled
uh florida more road rage incidents than
any other state we're number one
that's depressing a total of 147
incidents between those two years
uh so
this particular you know i don't know if
this is like uh statewide or nationwide
66 percent of traffic fatalities are
caused by aggressive driving
uh or aggressive drivers 37 percent of
aggressive driving incidents involve the
use of guns scary
and 50 percent of drivers who are on the
receiving end of an aggressive driver's
behavior respond back with additional
aggressive behavior which is why they
always tell you
if somebody
flips you off or
swears at you out the window or
something like that
do not
escalate it they even say do not make
eye contact with that person just keep
on keeping on because if you stop and
yell back at them or it's just gonna
like turn into a whole thing and
somebody's gonna end up getting shot so
that's basically what they tell you to
do they even say like don't even look at
the person they're like when you're
driving around don't even like excessive
eye contact or anything because some
people get offended by that so
but for sure like if you do something
dumb
like if you cut somebody off like you
didn't see them or something and they
start flipping out in the car behind you
like don't
engage just keep on going because you
know the [ __ ] could end badly
so as i said i had four cases kind of
like laid out but
while i was doing a little more research
today like kind of poking around
i found an incident that happened right
here in orlando
yesterday
nobody got killed but somebody got like
really really badly injured
and the person that did it is still at
large so isn't that fun so maybe we'll
be doing a public service
so here's what happened
uh this young woman named jessica myers
she was driving home
uh and i but her uh
and i believe her no her fiance wasn't
in the car but she was driving home
and
a man like cut her off like cut in front
of her
now i'm not blaming the victim but
everybody says like to keep road rage
from happening do not do this
she pulls up next to the guy and is
basically like hey what's the deal like
what's your problem what are you doing
seriously don't do that no matter how
stupid the person is that did it and
you'll see why not to uh so he cut her
off and she said
he cut me off i pulled up and said
what's wrong with you
she pulled up next to him
and then after that the guy starts
following her
so see that's why just keep on going
don't don't engage
uh
so the guy's following her
she calls her fiance whose name was
matthew on the phone
and she says hey um this guy just cut me
off and i said something to him and now
he's following me home
so
he says we'll just come home you know
it'll be it'll be fine
so she gets home and
her fiance and their grown son
come out
you know to make sure she's okay like
come out on the driveway
and then the person that was following
her
comes out
and the driver
ran over like hit the guy like the
fiancee with his car
like just ran in the [ __ ] driveway
he just like [ __ ] ran him over
so
i mean he it didn't kill him
but i saw pictures of him in the
hospital he looks pretty [ __ ] up
so
all that from just the girl being like
hey what are you doing like why'd you
cut me off
the dude follows her home and then like
runs over her fiance who came out to the
driveway to make sure she was all right
how old were these people involved i
missed a lot of this calm [ __ ] down i
don't really know
um they didn't look that old they looked
probably 30s maybe it was kind of hard
to tell if i could need a serious ass
i mean seriously like settle down
no okay but he looks kind of [ __ ] up i
mean he's he's pretty injured right um
let me see because i found this i wrote
this like uh this down and i was like
uh yeah driver is still at large uh
michael garan is hospitalized with
multiple injuries including fractured
vertebrae so it broke his back
um and uh his wrist also so he had to
you know oh and neither one of them has
medical insurance so they had to start a
gofundme
isn't that nice
but uh yeah so they're still looking for
the [ __ ] that did this cause
like i said
this is what kills me it's just kind of
like
people need to just [ __ ] let [ __ ] go
people do dumb [ __ ] while they're
driving it's gonna happen people are
idiots
just
let it
go
you know what i mean yeah or
who knows and worst worst [ __ ] is going
to happen later on like in some of these
sanity
from a very large population of people
there's always going to be a few insane
ones in there
well yeah bigger the the bigger the
crowd
the more you scale up and look down on
these little ants the more maniacs
you're gonna see well yeah i mean that's
just statistical but that's just the
price of society it's all like that
yeah i mean what you do lock everybody
up
and the thing about it is that
and i kind of try to think about it from
this point of view like i said from a
statistical point of view
most people
are fine most people wouldn't do that
most people would just be like oh
whatever what an idiot or and just would
go about their day
but the fact that
you know crime sells so you're gonna
hear about it and the more you hear
about it the more you think oh my god
everybody's crazy everybody's not crazy
you're just not hearing about the
majority people that aren't doing crazy
[ __ ] most people don't do stupid [ __ ]
like this you know what i mean
i mean it's more than it should be
probably but
most people wouldn't most people
wouldn't follow a girl that they had
just cut off because she was like hey
bro what the [ __ ] and then go and like
run over her [ __ ] fiance in their
[ __ ] driveway of their house most
people would not do that because that's
some crazy [ __ ] right there you know
but well dude's probably in a situation
where
he doesn't feel like he has any damn
control over his life and [ __ ] he's
being
[ __ ] on and he's under all this pressure
and somebody pisses him off and he's
like he's going to take vengeance out on
this person he doesn't even know
and he's looking at the car first
and then he realizes later on there's
somebody in that car and he transfers
the hatred from the car onto the person
yeah and he attacks the person it's
always easy okay look i'm gonna go back
to [ __ ] warfare
because i know all about this [ __ ] i
studied it from the masters some of the
best military units of all times i've
been in them
if you talk to [ __ ] fighter pilots in
world war ii it's real easy for these
guys to shoot it at another airplane and
watch it burst into flames
all right they go yeah gotcha you [ __ ]
they'll even [ __ ] put a damn
a little swastika or a japanese [ __ ]
rising sun on their plane just to score
that kill
but then you if you hear their [ __ ]
um
stories you know in their interviews
sometimes they actually get to see the
dude in the plane
burn it up
and and it affects them because all of a
sudden they're like oh yeah because like
i said it's easy to dehumanize when you
can't see
right it doesn't look like another human
without another human they're aiming at
they're aiming at an airplane at an
object and then they see the man in
there burning and they go oh [ __ ] that's
horrible yeah that's right another guy
yeah actions have consequences
well who knew well they're in a
gladiatorial arena he was done to him
it's killer be killed they're all doing
it to each other
it's just that it helps you dehumanize
or to desensitize yourself because it's
symbolic combat so what's happened to
these roads rage dudes price starts off
like that they just see a car making
them mad
yeah well yeah i mentioned that earlier
that it's very very easy to dehumanize
the average person no realizes when they
see the person they go ah [ __ ] him
and then they're able to dispel it
because it's not the car it's a person
and i don't want to get into it with the
person
but there's going to be a psychopath
like [ __ ] that car and [ __ ] those people
too i'm going to kill them people
so that's there's
that's why you don't see more of it yeah
because i i'm like that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] car is crazy and then i see
who's in it and i go there [ __ ] a [ __ ]
and then i feel better well the thing
about it is that i'm always just kind of
like look if somebody's driving like
real like they're racing okay i'm like
okay that person is clearly an idiot and
somebody needs to do something about
that but if somebody just does something
dumb like
you know oh they don't know where
they're at like they just stop real
quick to turn or they cut you off
because they didn't see you i'm willing
to give that because i've done dumb [ __ ]
too it's like look they're probably just
not super paying attention or they're
lost or something like that i'm not
gonna get [ __ ] aggro about a mistake
um if i'm gonna get mad it's gonna be at
somebody that's doing something clearly
on purpose which they do a lot on i-4
like i said they will race and like th
and they're absolutely doing that on
purpose that's not an accident like i
said i'm willing to give people the
benefit of the doubt for just being dumb
or not being super on the ball or not
super paying attention or they're maybe
they're inexperienced or something or
they didn't see you or whatever agnes
says you look beautiful jenny thank you
thank you everybody likes your hair you
look good with long black hair apart in
the middle jenny you do well that's why
i'm growing it back like i told you yeah
agnes said tom looks beautiful too
that goes without saying that goes
without saying oh but you have to well
everybody has to tell me but you already
know that
so much beauty all in one spot oh my god
don't make me take my clothes off
don't make me take no no one's making
you
no one's making you it's so earthy
you're not even drunk yet come on now
okay okay is that wait is that your
first drink that's two but that's but
these are this is like a trouble oh okay
this is triple oh that's already the
second oh my god we're in trouble i'm
drinking basically a fish tank
he's like i'm gonna get me a damn fish
bowl to drink out of i dare you to put
to fit well i was gonna say i dare you
to put the fish in don't drink a real
fish
in the little fishies well i was gonna
say you could put a fake fish in there
like you could put a gummy you could put
a gummy fish in there right that was
like the size of a goldfish i would
never have you like swallow a real
goldfish that's [ __ ] up
tina's going laughing at me and then she
goes yeah we don't know what you're
talking about just just been talking
about when i was talking about the uh
mad at the car and then you see the
person that's probably what she's
talking about rick shaw says ban cars
turn roads into roller discos i'm down
then it'll be [ __ ] like roller derby
out there
but yeah so but yeah i was mentioning
that earlier that's why i like road
that's why you don't see too much
well i don't know you do kind of see
people
in like for example like a grocery store
line like punched but you don't usually
see that because that's a person you can
see that it's a person yeah it's not
like an object
and it's much much harder
to
actually just come out and like punch a
[ __ ] in the face that's right
there that's you know if it's just like
an old lady or something like that
you know not impossible i will say but
it's harder
much easier if it's
you don't see it as a person
um so yeah so that just happened
yesterday in florida so hopefully that
guy will be okay and they catch whoever
the [ __ ] did that because that is uh
monumentally [ __ ] up now uh only 14
states have uh laws against aggressive
driving interestingly
and only one state which is california
uh has
a
has road rage as like a legal term like
the rest of it i guess it's kind of they
have to just put it under different
statutes or whatever
now this uh i found this was interesting
uh cities where road rage is most common
does anybody want to guess
the cities where moro rays are mo
the cities where road rage is mostly
america's city american cities yeah uh
new york
yep
and
uh san francisco nope new york chicago
nope
new york
miami yep okay crazy [ __ ] miami
uh i think miami has taken the cake the
last three years
uh but our our ones are new york detroit
okay yeah atlanta yeah big guys is in
all the situations where my sister lives
in atlanta and she's like yeah
everyone's [ __ ] lunatics yeah uh
phoenix
miami houston cincinnati yeah and san
diego okay yeah there's a those those
cities are all worlds apart in culture
there's the reason why you know [ __ ]
but they're all big
well yeah but okay granters he can be
here i don't know if he's still here
because you know i lived in detroit too
this [ __ ] happens in detroit because
it's it's a large sparsely populated
it's like a [ __ ]
beirut it's a bombed out destroyed city
it's like mad max
it happens there because it can
if somebody makes you mad nobody's
watching you can just start [ __ ]
shooting and killing people there
looks like some [ __ ] straight out of
predator now predator was going down
[ __ ] trying to kill all the hunting
the gangsters and the the cops and the
[ __ ] gangsters fighting yeah really
that really should have been happening
in detroit
you could go down there and just shoot
people
because they do it
yep yeah they just
for a while when i was when i was there
it was the murder capital of the [ __ ]
world
it was a rapidly declining population of
people killing each other because of the
drug trade and it's just a [ __ ]
insane collapsing economy and
corruption
and it but when you looked at it it was
peaceful
because it was very sparsely populated
for a city that size mostly empty
buildings
so you didn't get a scope of it you know
it's not like new york
yeah it was weird it was quiet
really you know
this is so each one of these places it's
happening for different reasons yeah
miami is not a [ __ ] bad place miami's
[ __ ] bumping it's fun it's latin
salsa and [ __ ] cuban food and cuban
people and great nightclubs and cona
it's like central america it's like a
very high-end central american city
and
they're not immigrants they've been here
longer than the united states
you've got to remember the united states
purchased well
we got florida in a in a peace
settlement against spain
so it was already hispanic
territory which is weird like why when
people say immigrants i'm like they're
not immigrants they've been here longer
than we have yeah yeah
well a lot of this immigrant immigrants
this and that this is coming from
mythologies
coming from the northeast
and universities where they're
projecting the northeastern situation
onto the rest of the united states not
knowing the history of all these states
texas was always half american and half
excuse me half
texas was always half mexican and half
irish from day one
it was mexican and irish cattle
ranchers
and it was like a joint venture between
a rich mexican family and a rich little
irish cowboy family
making a state and they made their own
little independent [ __ ] republic
um
florida was always
spain spanish empire you know and
it had a
a a
situation kind of more like central
america and it had a good uh
caribbean kind of a vibe to it like
pirates of the caribbean and [ __ ] you
know what i mean well i was just going
to say florida is spain native americans
and pirates yeah yeah
pretty much and louisiana i don't think
people think of it like that but that's
exactly what it's like and louisiana is
french pirates
and africans
and voodoo and [ __ ] the mixing of all
these cultures
and then you go well not not
mississippi and alabama that's white as
snow little do you know no
mississippi is german and same with
alabama there was no
alabama i think alabama broke off from
mississippi or mississippi broke off
from alabama i don't remember but at one
time they were the same states
it was a mixture
of germans irish
and africans and spaniards
and it was they were always mixed there
was not
they were not um
uh uh which it wasn't they weren't
homogeneous
they just weren't like
i have spanish names and french names
you know in in my family you know my
[ __ ] middle name is francis this is a
french [ __ ] name my grandfather's
name was bolivar it was a [ __ ]
spanish name
so
but it was basically an irish and german
family but there was a lot of french and
spanish influence in it you know and
everybody is like that who was a native
of these uh and and we all kind of had a
little bit of native american in us to
jenny's part native american but me and
jenny probably real close racially irish
german
native american
you know
maybe probably a little bit of french or
spanish in her you know but
so it was never just this [ __ ] ultra
white boy paradise scandinavian you know
with his vikings no that's up north
you know michigan that's [ __ ] fine
yeah that's like midwest
upper midwest yeah more than anything
yeah [ __ ] we have [ __ ] sophie
benjaminson our friend friend of the
show who's been on shows with sophie
she's a [ __ ]
viking ice princess you know [ __ ] you
look at it she looks like she's straight
from
sweden you know
and you know most of a lot of michigan
and ohio's like that
rebecca says jenny where did san diego
rate on the list what number they were
eighth actually i got like the top eight
and that was new york detroit atlanta
phoenix miami houston cincinnati san
diego those are like stoppie
those are the most common road rage
cities
uh least common for road rage behavior i
don't have as many cities for that but
uh denver
which is interesting my sister used to
live there as well portland oregon uh
that was one of the lowest ones and uh
most cities in ohio also states that
didn't have a lot of road rage georgia
tennessee missouri and minnesota
so
there was that as well like i said i
kind of feel like like you said the the
cities that have the most road rage
it's not
i mean i'm not saying it's not
necessarily the cities you would think
it was but
it's a different situation it's not like
you can just say oh it's this thing or
that thing or the other thing honestly i
think any time you have a big city
with a lot of people in it and a lot of
people driving
you're gonna get this because that just
kind of happens with humans anyway like
just when they're all kind of crammed
together close
like in close proximity there's gonna be
like some tempers flaring you know what
i mean because everybody that lives in a
big city
uh you know has said everyone the
drivers here are crazy
and somebody just said earlier like
tampa drivers are crazy they are
central florida in general
is pretty crazy and somebody said
earlier too uh bundy data said
uh i4 is notorious
and for good reason i mean i'm not
saying that it's the craziest place i've
ever driven
but it's nothing compared to brazil it's
pretty bad
i mean
the thing about and well the thing about
i-42 and we have uh this another
additional thing to add to i-4 that
maybe some other cities don't have
is that we also have a fuck-ton of
tourists
like going to disney and stuff like that
that have no [ __ ] idea where they're
going
or are just kind of like
clueless
and so they're kind of all over the road
or going super slow because they're
looking at everything so there's that
too so we also have that we're looking
at their gps
yeah i mean it's better it's probably
better now that it was because back in
the old days like when everybody just
had paper maps and everybody was getting
lost all the time it was probably like a
lot worse like now at least you have
like [ __ ] gps to tell you where to go
yeah but
you got to put your sexual training
that's my sexual tyrannosaur hat on
gotta i'm gonna get more [ __ ] sexy
involved in this [ __ ]
that's super sexy yeah i'm getting
really sexy hold on i gotta pee
when was the last time tom put on a wig
i was thinking about that earlier like i
took his his beautiful like black danzig
wig
but he still has his
mullet wig and he still has his k-pop
wig which he never wears he still has
his mozart wig
or his founding father wig if you want
to call it that which he hasn't worn in
a long time but
maybe we should maybe we should like try
to subtly talk him into putting on the
mozart wig
okay um okay where was i yeah they used
i-4 as a straight run race course
honestly and look i love
going out but
if i i would be happy if i never had to
drive on i-4 ever again like
now that i work at home i don't have to
work i don't have to drive on i-4
anymore which is nice
if i ever do
really the only other time sometimes i
have to go to meetings to like this one
client
and
it would be quicker going there on i-4
but
[ __ ] that noise i usually i always go
the back way because i'm just i'm not
getting on there i'm just not
um
the thing about it they've improved the
road a lot like in the last few years
they actually have widened it they made
some um turnaround lanes in the middle
that are uh toll roads
so that are like express lanes so that's
kind of helped a little bit with the
congestion but when i was commuting
i4
was like a [ __ ]
parking lot
any weekday
um
and it didn't even matter if it was just
kind of like because i used to work from
um probably like eight in the morning to
like 6 6 30 at night
and so obviously it was like bad getting
there it took me like an hour and a half
to get to a job that was
maybe 10 miles away 15 miles something
like that 12 miles
and and then it would take me like
another hour and a half to get back home
so it was like another three hours
because you would just sit there and
just crawl and crawl and crawl because
it was just like [ __ ]
and it's a parking lot like for miles
and miles and miles terrible but they
have done some improvements i don't
we'll see how how it goes i mean they
have a lot of toll roads
they've added those express lanes
they did smooth everything out they
fixed some [ __ ]
honestly like last time we went downtown
which is probably like a few weeks ago
now
uh or like a month ago they've really
done a nice job they widened that part
of like i4 like all of the exits and
stuff are like much nicer
it's much less hazardous like the
visibility is much better they put like
all these big lights up so you can
actually kind of see where you're going
at night so you know they have actually
been working on it but the thing about
i4 is that they're always working on it
somewhere and then by the time they're
done working on it then they have to
start over where they started working on
it like a few years ago because now
that's old so now they have to fix that
and because people keep moving here and
it just keeps like expanding and
expanding so i don't know he's trying to
get me to put a wig on well i told you i
was like you haven't like put the mozart
one no yeah or
well tila said the long black one i was
like this is his long black one like i
said i stole his danzig hair i don't
actually have a long black band
finally made it to another live jenny if
you could tell tom pat made a new
facebook and to react it must be pat
monstercraft is that what you're talking
about i don't know okay that's the only
pattern i know i can think of
yeah yeah if you want to put the mozart
wig on yeah you haven't worn that a long
time or or the mullet i'll put it on
i'll put something on or the mullet
what's up whenever or the k-pop wig
the k-pop win i think you wore that like
one time although to be honest i put
that on one time and i'm like hey that's
pretty cute yeah
that looks kind of cute on me i think
you could put a k-pop on
well you know
uh monstercraft okay okay she said
monster crap monster crap
crap
monster crap
what's the matter pokey she's throwing
that little [ __ ]
house she's throwing her toys
i bought her because she remember i said
how she loves brush and i can't even
brush my hair i have to go in the
bathroom and close both doors and lock
them
to brush my hair because if i pull the
brush out she's like
yeah
so i bought her these little things that
like stick on the corner of the wall
that are like brushes and they have
catnip in them
oh my god look at her she's spazzing
yeah she's trying to kill she's trying
to monster craft all right oh okay
monster crap yeah
it's monster cats
is marineland still just south of
daytona
um
i think it's gone yeah i the last time i
went over in that area because i went to
saint augustine back in june of last
year so almost a year ago
and there were still signs for it and i
was like holy [ __ ] is that still open i
haven't been to that since i was little
um i used to love marine layers there's
only really one i don't think it's there
anymore there are only two
there are only two
good theme parks you need to go to when
you come to florida
universal universal [ __ ] blows disney
out of the [ __ ] water
and i i you know i i i'm not i don't
think he has disney just that
last couple times i went it just that
that park looks like [ __ ] all right
universal and jesus land you got to go
to [ __ ] jesus the holy land tour
i've never been but i want to see it
because i i don't want to goof on it i
don't want to pay yeah you know i want
to i want to just go to say yeah i went
to it
because i kind of want to go too but i
don't want to pay yeah
i read about it like it's small
it is you could probably like
do the [ __ ] in like two hours yeah
easily
they got all kinds of [ __ ] down there
man they got a little sling shots where
they get in there and they sling shots
you around well orlando is all it's all
based around tourism tourism all of it
we don't really have i mean citrus we
have that and like strawberries and [ __ ]
um we have some agriculture but honestly
particularly central florida tourism so
in this area pretty much everything is
geared toward tourism yeah that's good
though that's good
tourism is always around it this is an
entertainment this is a party central
about partying
going in restaurants
strip clubs got one of the best strip
clubs rachel's
[ __ ] they got good steaks in there steak
yeah got a good steak
uh restaurants uh just [ __ ] clubs
some of the best clubs
and just uh it's just like a normal
place it's just fun
kind of mashed together
country and city and
it's just
i've been all over the world this is a
weird place i've been all over the world
there's no place like the orlando
there's no place like florida
it's a place of extremes it's like a
very high
end
louisiana it's like louisiana on
steroids
more wealth
but it is kind of like louisiana
a little bit
well there's kind of like there's
it's there's little bits of everything
yeah because
florida is kind of like where everybody
ends up yeah you know what i mean
everybody comes here because the
weather's nice i mean although that's
arguable from all kinds of biker events
all kinds of biker events
biker girls
[ __ ] uh
i mean there's a massive massive bike
[ __ ] biker scene
big
just if you if you're into bikers if
you're into race cars you're in a
redneck [ __ ] yeah horses
one of the biggest [ __ ] horse [ __ ]
farms is just just up the street here
they have whole [ __ ]
it's like it's like the daytona 500. i
don't know the name of that farm
you know what i'm talking about yeah
yeah we passed that yeah we passed that
the other day and you go there and it's
like a trailer park because there's
[ __ ]
they were doing like a huge there was a
huge thing yeah remember we went we went
to the [ __ ] oyster trough the other
day and i was like holy [ __ ] what's
going on in there it looks like [ __ ]
disneyland yeah they show them tour
buses yeah and the tour but these are
beautiful tour buses
like rock stars
and their trail trail and [ __ ]
racehorses with them and [ __ ] show
horses and they're having huge events
over here i don't know the name of that
[ __ ] place and i was in the horse
business i'd have to ask my mom what it
was because she said oh well that place
it's worth [ __ ] 10 million dollars
that's a massive mess it's a massive
place where they just have horse events
you know [ __ ] but uh no
great [ __ ] food
even in this little area out here great
food the [ __ ] seafood's [ __ ] great
it's just an unspoiled area
everybody's moving out here to have
[ __ ] a good time and uh they're not
part of they're not about all this
nonsense
and it's just
it's not overcrowded yet
it'll overcrowd eventually some places
are overcrowded it'll become like it'll
become like california
but i'll be dead by the time it becomes
like that it'll take another 30 years
but i'll be dead by them so i don't care
like i said it's a weird place it's kind
of a place where
everybody comes to so there's kind of
like influences from everywhere it's not
one thing no it's a bunch of [ __ ] it's a
bunch of different [ __ ] it's got a good
goth scene it's got a good photo which
you wouldn't think but it actually
really does it actually really does it
has a natural defense system a natural
barrier heat and humidity and that keeps
a lot of the [ __ ] riffraff out of
here
because you have i hate it too but i'm
only here because you have to want to be
here because i'm i was born here and i
can't afford to leave you you have to
want to be here
that [ __ ] heat and humidity if during
the summer [ __ ] drives all the
weaklings out
it's really not it's no joke seriously
yeah and like i said i was born here and
i still hate it yeah i still hate it
and it's i don't know
i i wish it was a good state i wish it's
a good statement i could live somewhere
where there were seasons yeah
you know what i mean it reminds me i've
been all over the united states there's
no seasons it's been all over the united
states but all over the world
it reminds me
of all of the real goods it has all the
good parts of a bunch of states that i
like to combine into one state it's a
mishmash of a lot of stuff
it's like louisiana and california
and brazil
and um mississippi
and
and and [ __ ] and [ __ ] las vegas
and
and everything all just rolled into one
you know
it's hot though and you better get ready
for that [ __ ]
it's just the way it is bring your baby
powder you're going to need that [ __ ]
and your uh bug spray yeah
yeah and uh what i do like about it is
that you don't have to have a lot of
money
like we got money around here there's
[ __ ] rich people we're in a rich
neighborhood you don't need a whole lot
of money to live around here i just go
up the street go to the biker bar
there's [ __ ] poor people in there
[ __ ] crackhead girls and [ __ ] you
know what i mean it's just it's such a
mixed area
it's a mixed income it's just everybody
it's because it's just life
yeah you never really know what you're
gonna come across to be honest right i
mean as i mentioned earlier the
uh you know the kind of
it's cheaper to live here yeah but if
you have to have a job here it doesn't
pay as much as a similar job would pay
elsewhere no but it doesn't require as
much here though it's cheaper
yeah so i mean depends on what city
you're into you're going to say you know
not only the city the the county yeah
it depends on your county so it depends
but like i said uh wages in florida do
tend to be lower
uh for similar jobs like than other
cities so don't
if you have like a high high-paying job
like somewhere else don't expect to get
paid the same in florida because you
won't no
but but cause like i said a little
further here [ __ ] like i've been a
graphic designer for more than 20 years
i don't think i ever made more than
thirteen fourteen dollars an hour which
is nothing yeah nothing right
uh and an actual job but that goes quite
far in florida it's a little further not
not as far as i would like that would be
nothing in california that's what i'm
saying to be able to own anything but
i'd be making more out there too but
that's you know i'm just saying that
you're living like this out there though
that's true you just wouldn't it's like
so you have to like understand that
there's like a trade-off and like i said
it is hot
as [ __ ] i was gonna and i'm not even
talking about like hot like desert hot
it is like swamp human
you will have like
sweaty ass crack like sweat under your
boobs like all the time yeah so just
know that know that okay i was gonna
show some biker fun
oh before we get into the stuff okay
hold on one second
this is
this is the little [ __ ] crackhead
that's good
rebecca tell me that story
again it's every best stories again
again
i gotta get that [ __ ] on the show i
gotta get that [ __ ] on the show that you
said what'd you say now what'd you say
what was
that's that girl he was talking about
that was rebecca and we're talking about
her in uh last week but like i said i'm
not really entirely sure like she
obviously did not want you to film her
and i'm just kind of like i don't know
how comfortable i am with you like
[ __ ] filming like
obviously schizophrenic girl
for like amusement purposes
that's that cool i'm not worried about
not cool
well obviously you're not worried about
it
agnes says i hate humid and i hate heat
yeah yeah um probably florida would not
be for you it's really not like i said i
was born here and i'm not a fan
uh it's
really uncomfortable
uh for a large portion of the year
it doesn't ever really get cold like
sometimes it gets cold
but
what are you doing
do you mind doing the show
i was uh on
instagram and that was gia playing
guitar
okay yeah but like we're doing a show
though so knock it off
[Laughter]
but yeah i'm just saying it's it's not
uh i don't like it i don't like it
it's hot
it's been it's hot at christmas time
yeah it's hot at thanksgiving
it's hot it's just always hot yeah
every now and then it'll get cold and
i'll get really excited about it but it
like it never gets under
yeah 30. degrees
like when it goes under 30 degrees i'm
like oh my god it's winter for one day
or maybe two days and then that's and
then it's over and i'm like
is northern part of florida as bad as
the rest as far as the weather
uh it's worse well wait the northern
part of florida well northern partisan
won't be as hot as it is here but it's
not really that much of a difference to
be honest like central florida south
florida
that's going to be hottest obviously and
it's very very like i said it's swampy
even like central florida orlando
uh orlando it was built on a swamp
it's a swamp
and south florida is a swamp
um so if you're not really into like
super super hot and just being like
[ __ ] damp and sweaty all the time
yeah
then this is not for you maniac says i
couldn't be a florida goth because goth
clothes are not designed for florida
yeah yeah you're kind of right i mean
it's a lot of fishnet
a lot of [ __ ] short no
death rock almost kind of look
fishnets [ __ ]
um
sleeveless shirts [ __ ] pants and
boots you could you can do it but dude
how many times
how many times in the summer yeah have i
been like okay it's like really hot out
tonight it's like are my eyebrows
still on or have they melted off yeah
because it's like
110 [ __ ] degrees okay so what's the
next case on this all right so we're
finally getting to that all right yeah
yeah
yeah no swamp
yeah florida goths have it rough without
yeah it's it's a struggle i'm just i'm
gonna say that and honestly i have a lot
of really nice clothes in my closet that
i can't
wear
i mean i maybe wear them like one time a
year when it's
cold enough and this past year it didn't
really get cold enough
we had a couple cold nights but
nothing all that i i was kind of like
wish there was winter but i don't know i
didn't like i said i need to go
somewhere there's seasons this kind of
it's bumped me out i don't know
all right so
so i talked about this like the [ __ ]
that happened like in orlando like
yesterday right
now this other case that i had written
down this also happened in florida
i promise it didn't all happen in
florida but this one did too
uh and this happened in a place i didn't
even know this place existed this place
is called beverly hills now apparently
it's only 80 miles from orlando
but i never heard of it but it's called
beverly hills i'm like okay this
happened back in late july of 2015.
now
okay this is some [ __ ] up [ __ ] right
here so we're going to get into a
discussion about this
because i listened to
part of the 9-1-1 calls on this because
there were several competing 9-1-1 calls
going on for this
so
there's two cars
no one's entirely sure
who started this altercation
okay
but we have
uh
one guy
who
i don't know if he cut one guy off or if
the other guy cut him off and then he
got mad and then there was this whole
thing
but
they both had their wives in the car
the one guy whose spoiler alert ended up
getting shot and killed
had his
wife
his daughter
and his grandson in the car the other
guy just had his wife in the car
so they're on the road
and
something happened nobody saw the first
part of this but they both the both of
their wives called 911
like i said this is late july 2015.
now one of the guys that's in the car is
named candelario gonzalez he was 44.
the other guy is named eric doyle he's
51.
uh and this is in florida beverly hills
which is about 80 miles northwest of
orlando which like i said i never heard
of that city so that just goes just goes
to show and i've lived around here my
whole life never heard of beverly
hills um
so what happened
is that something
took place somebody cut somebody off
somebody flipped somebody off and
somebody got aggravated nobody knows
exactly who the aggressor was exactly
but candelario gonzalez
um
[Music]
she's telling her wife you could or
she's telling her husband you can hear
it on the 911 call
apparently he decides this other dude
eric doyle
um has done some [ __ ] up [ __ ] he's
like i'm gonna follow him home
and get his license number that's what
he's thinking of
his wife is trying to convince him
wisely um yeah [ __ ] it just go home
let's not get involved in this um you
know let's just go home
and that'll be the end of it
um she even says and i listen to the
we're not gonna 911 him there she says
he says oh i'm gonna follow him right to
his house i don't know what this guy did
but they got into like some kind of
altercation on the road and he's like
gotta follow him he's gonna get his uh
his license number
now at this point eric doyle his wife
who is in his car
has also called 9-1-1
and
doyle says
uh to the operator the 911 operator i'm
going home
the guns are coming out and i'm going to
put it to his [ __ ] head that's what
he says on the 911 call because i heard
it
later on he decides he's driving his
house and i guess uh candelario gonzalez
and his wife were following him like i
said they were trying to get his license
number because of whatever happened
earlier
and then he says they're following me to
my house i'll be there in 20 seconds the
guns are already out that's what he says
so
they go to eric doyle's house
and i guess candelario gonzalez and his
wife like followed him there
and then
eric doyle's wife can be heard on the
911 call saying don't shoot i've got 911
on
the phone
but you can clearly hear five shots on
the 911 call
eric doyle
got candelario gonzalez out of his car
and shot him five times in front of his
wife
his daughter damn and his seven-year-old
grandson
and kept the wife and the children at
gunpoint until the cops got there
because he apparently felt threatened
because this person followed him to his
house they were just trying to they were
trying to get apparently they were
trying to get his
license number or they were you know
i don't know what happened prior to that
because like i said they don't have a
recording of that they only have like
the 911 call so he basically shot
candelaria gonzalez dead for taking
pictures of his license plate
i guess i don't know
yeah
word to people
keep that [ __ ] phone in your damn
pocket don't take pictures of people
you don't understand how a [ __ ]
is going to react i was like don't do
anything just just assume that everyone
is a maniac yeah that's it that's what i
do i was at starbucks one time and had
some scientologists
oh boy yeah
start making fun of me because i was
wearing motorcycle armor
and they started acting funny the woman
that was with them was like cool
about it she said oh yeah which is is
that from and she wanted to know why i
was wearing striker armor when it's a
good thing on right i'm like so i don't
have scientologists i don't get hurt
when i crash like why is that why is
that weird because they're [ __ ]
scientologists
so i [ __ ] went and says look what the
[ __ ] are you talking about dude and they
all pulled their phones out
had i been crazy
i'd have [ __ ] those dudes up for
pulling the phones out i mean they're
scientologists so they probably had it
right they probably had it kind of i
i would have popped that one dude right
in the top of his head pink listen to
him in front of the other ones to get
that [ __ ] on camera but i wasn't as
[ __ ] psycho i wasn't as [ __ ]
suicidal you know i'm not suicidal you
know what i mean
um
i have too much [ __ ] to lose at this
point you know
had they got me a [ __ ] 10 years ago
20 years ago it would have been
different you know what i mean i
wouldn't have done i wouldn't have taken
that well
and here's the deal
they still have people
like that now running around
you know well there's always like a new
crop of you yeah yeah right
you go down to the [ __ ] oasis
go down there go down there and [ __ ]
around with some biker gangs and do that
and see what happens
you're gonna
you might think you're the toughest man
in the world you're gonna come out of
there wearing high heels and have a
g-string on when they're done with you
make you feel like a woman
all right you're going to think you're
in a maximum security prison because
that's where they come from
that you know well i kind of feel like
that's the reason why yeah you know i
just think this entire like [ __ ] right i
don't know that's why road rage like i
said i've done it before myself i
understand getting angry at people doing
stupid [ __ ] or
you know not even stupid [ __ ] but like
aggressive [ __ ] that's what makes me mad
i don't get mad at people doing like
dumb [ __ ] because i do dumb [ __ ]
people that do stuff on purpose like
trying to
run you off the road on purpose or
something like that yeah that makes me
mad but if you're just doing something
dumb because you're not paying attention
that doesn't make me mad because you're
just an idiot i don't care that's not
you know that's it you know you're not
being like aggressive on purpose you're
just like doing you're just being a
dummy
tina comes in he goes man i feel like a
woman tina you need to feel like a woman
you go to go get your man
and get him on the show and let him
watch and we're going to talk about what
kind of woman you are
i mean with that with with it with she's
laughing
she's in there laughing
i mean okay so the thing about this
particular case and this is it gets
[ __ ] crazier
the thing about this particular case i
don't really know what happened before
the 9-1-1 calls because both of their
wives called
and i will note that both of their wives
wisely told them to like knock it the
[ __ ] off uh the wife of candelaria
gonzales said please don't follow this
dude home
and the wife of the
other dude eric doyle said uh please
knock it off and don't shoot him
uh neither of the dudes listened much to
their detriment so just gonna put that
out there
but so that i don't know what went on
before that i don't know who was the
aggressor
uh going by past history um and even the
investigation at the time said that eric
doyle the guy that ended up shooting and
killing the guy uh was probably the
aggressor even though he tried to play
victim later on but like i said i don't
know exactly what happened
uh and even at the time like the the
sheriff's captain whatever like he said
um oh well i just like shot people
because like i thought my wife was in
danger
and the sheriff were like yeah we don't
really buy that so
okay
um they said and this was a quote from
an article i found between the evidence
that was found on scene uh couple that
with the 911 calls we felt comfortable
that mr doyle who was the murderer was
the primary aggressor
uh he does have a concealed weapons
permit so the gun that he was uh holding
was not illegal
um he did actually have permission to
have that in his vehicle it just seems
really weird how he thought like oh
somebody's following him he's like oh my
god i feel so like threatened and he i
don't know i just to me it just seemed
like you wanted excuse to shoot somebody
but whatever
um
now
so they arrested him because he [ __ ]
killed a dude in front of his entire
family
so there was that
so they arrested him and they charged
him with second-degree murder
and aggravated assault with a deadly
weapon however
a little over a year after this incident
in september of 2016
they dropped all charges against him
citing uh they they said he acted in
self-defense
that he actually thought
that maybe he was in danger from an
unarmed man driving with his wife and
children
in his car who followed him back to his
house
to get his information which like i said
was probably not the wisest move but
doesn't deserve getting killed over
uh but yeah so this dude like guns down
to dude in front of his entire family
and he got off with it so i had to be
there to see it hooray if well if if the
jury
said that
the jury thought
that he was being
that he was defending himself i i had to
find out more about it because it's
possible let's say that's the same thing
that happened with that black dude that
was running through that neighborhood
you had uh some guys
running them down in the truck they had
some shotguns i saw the video
they said look we want to stop we want
to talk to you stop we want to talk to
you
and the dude [ __ ] turned around
[ __ ] grab a shotgun and then [ __ ]
that dude shot him for grabbing the
shotgun
there's two different ways of looking at
that
he you could say he thought he was being
pursued by some guys in a truck with
[ __ ] guns and running for his life
when they [ __ ] jump on him
he [ __ ] grabs the gun to defend
himself but then they shoot him
but you could also say from the other
point of view we wanted to question him
we were [ __ ]
we thought he was stealing some stuff
and [ __ ] you know what i mean you
could say
they got convicted
it was a similar situation to that they
followed him
you're not really supposed to be
following people you know
depending on what jurisdiction you're in
here's the here's the thing people
everybody wants to live in a world of
right and wrong
everybody wants to live in a world with
rules
there aren't any rules
rich people decide who what the rules
are you threaten a rich person
they don't they're a billionaire they
own corporations they dictate to you
what the rules are
to defend themselves
that's just how it is
we want to live in a room in a world
that has rules but it really doesn't
it's all situational
black dude that was running i could see
that maybe he was scared that dudes were
chasing it
but i could also see it from the other
point of view guys thought he was
stealing something they wanted to talk
to him
i could see that point but i could see
that point too
um
if i were to call on it i would say the
dudes that wanted to talk to the guy
probably were in the right
because they kind of saw themselves as
defending their own neighborhood i
really don't care about what wrote what
what laws are i think laws are
are
a social construct made up by white
people there really shouldn't be laws
there should just be [ __ ]
dealing out damage to other people and
it should be a mafia really is what it
is because when you look through
history over the thousands of years
that's really what it was
human natures are just groups they're
tribal groups and they're mafias
so i don't [ __ ] look for right and
wrong in these people
it's not a world of good and evil it's a
world of evil and evil evil versus evil
that's what it really is
but i'm okay with that
was this dude in a wrong
i don't know i don't even care to me it
kind of well i don't care
they're all bad
okay
whatever
they're all bad
that's that's very insightful of you
yeah yeah so anyway
[Laughter]
anyway
uh where was i so yeah i'm so i'm [ __ ]
up anyway yeah i obviously
thank you you're being very helpful
so uh so yeah it's just kind of like
okay
i feel like
as much i i guess he was successful in
like painting himself as the victim like
he thought that he was in danger from
this person
um but it's pretty clear from the 911
call that his wife was telling him hey
don't shoot that guy hey don't shoot
that guy like i'm on the phone with that
woman right now you can hear the [ __ ]
gunshots on the 911 call
um he just kind of had them lined up
outside the car
and it seemed like he just shot the dude
and every and then he just like held the
gun on the rest of the family until the
cops got there um
i don't really think that he was in any
danger
um
and i think he just used that as an
excuse but
okay whatever uh i'm sure he was
terrified of this
person that was in this car
and he just had to shoot them and now
they're dead so great uh but yeah he got
off and he's still running around so
that's
fantastic uh so here's another one that
happened
october 22nd 2015.
a man named alan garcia he had just
picked up his two kids from a school in
albuquerque new mexico
he's trying to get off the freeway and
another car comes and like tries to
force him out of the lane don't know why
exactly but you know people are [ __ ]
like that and that's what they do
so because the guy tried to like force
him out of the lane um alan garcia kind
of like makes a gesture at him is like
swearing like what the [ __ ] man like
most people would uh i would definitely
do that
but they tell you not to but like i said
it's blaming the victim but
in a lot of ways it's just kind of like
hey don't get yourself killed over like
some stupid [ __ ] that doesn't matter so
there's that too
so he's swearing at the other guy and
like you know gesturing at him
uh and at that point the other guy in
the car
who
um obviously had some
issues
opens fire
on alan garcia's truck
and this he opens fire and it ends up
hitting his four-year-old daughter
who was also in the car
in the head
and killed her
so there's that everybody [ __ ] calm
down seriously
uh so yeah
one guy cuts off another guy one guy has
the audacity to say hey what the [ __ ]
why are you cutting me off and then he's
like oh well i don't like that somebody
told me that i cut somebody off so i'm
just gonna open fire and kill your
four-year-old kid
that's nice
uh so yeah alan garcia tells the cops uh
i heard two gunshots his seven-year-old
son
uh who was also in the car
uh says to his dad you know that his
little sister was bleeding uh this is
which is horrible and look at pookie
like took over the [ __ ] coho seat
what are you doing you're gonna be
co-spoke okay
so yeah
uh they actually did identify the
suspect later on it was a dude named
tony torres
now after he had opened fire to the car
he didn't know that he'd actually shot a
little girl in the head not that it
makes it any better
but
he kept chasing alan garcia's truck and
fired two more times
uh at which point alan garcia as you
would like he pulls over and he's trying
to give first stage his daughter and he
calls 911 and stuff like that because
obviously his daughter is bleeding
profusely
at this point his daughter's name was
lily by the way
and she was like laying on the tailgate
now they actually did end up finding
tony torres a couple days after this
incident
now when they caught him he did admit
to shooting at the family uh as they
were driving this is interstate 40 in
albuquerque that's kind of the main
east-west freeway in albuquerque new
mexico
and he got charged with uh murder
assault child abuse and uh a bunch of
other crimes
and ended up doing a court appearance
from uh from jail via video now he had a
650 000 cash only bond
what ended up happening was that
they caught him
because
i guess like he
i don't know if like he turned himself
in or if somebody that saw it like
turned him in so basically tony torres
allegedly
cut off alan garcia
alan garcia had the audacity to say hey
what the [ __ ] are you doing to like
swear at him at which point tony torrez
takes it up
a hundred notches and starts shooting
into his car and kills his four-year-old
daughter who was in the back seat so no
that's nice
um
you know
so two nurses show up to this to the
site
try to save the little girl uh ambulance
came and they took her to the hospital
but unfortunately she passed away a
four-year-old girl lily gonzalez died
because her dad swore at somebody so you
know
now uh i think what ended up happening
like the after this incident happened
like i said this back in 2015
the cops put out a thing for like 25 000
dollars informationally to rest whatever
uh they knew what the car looked like
and uh they knew they had a spoiler they
had tinted windows and that had a
university of new mexico license plate
and there was all like all kind of like
[ __ ]
public outcry about it obviously because
it was like a little four-year-old
four-year-old girl
um
when they caught tony torres
it turned out that he had a bunch of
not convictions but he had a bunch of uh
kind of like
violations in the past that he had
somehow wiggled his way out of
um
so like over the past 10 years now the
only crime that he actually got
prosecuted for
was like a misdemeanor it was like
speeding
but
uh because he pleaded guilty to that
but prior to that
he also had other uh you know
he also had other charges against him
like a child of child abuse
aggravated battery
uh of a household member there was that
um
and the aggravated battery
case the victim died i don't know if
they died as a result of the aggravated
battery or
if something else was going on but
because presumably the victim was going
gonna be testifying against him
when they died like the charges were
dropped so there was that
uh he'd also been accused of domestic
violence in 2006
and but somehow wiggled out of that as
well
so
this was clearly not um
a real stable person
that was driving around that couldn't
even like deal with one person
swearing at them
when they
cut him off in traffic and killed a
four-year-old girl because of it like i
said everybody [ __ ] calmed down
now so
finally december of 2016 uh he got
sentenced to 16 years in prison on a
murder charge
now
he did apologize to the girl's family
which
fine but you know a little bit of an
empty gesture at that point
so he actually got a plea deal
um i think they were gonna give him the
death penalty but he got a plea deal
because uh he
he got a couple cases of assault and uh
first degree murder dismissed and then
he put in
an offered pr an offered plea to
second-degree murder if you don't know
what an offer plea is it's basically
you're not admitting any guilt
but you're also saying yeah you have
enough evidence to convict me if this
actually does go to trial so that's what
he's gonna do so he pleaded that to
second-degree murder uh so he got that
now at the trial he said and this is a
quote i'm sorry for taking the life of
lily i had no intention of hurting
anyone that day i asked for forgiveness
from the bottom of my heart i thought i
was going to be the next road rage
victim he just had to put that little
i'm the victim thing at the end though
didn't he he killed a [ __ ]
four-year-old girl over nothing
so
sorry you know excuse me if i'm not
really all that sympathetic
uh but yeah he said oh i feared for my
life because blah blah blah i'm like
yeah i'm sure you probably didn't
it's just it i don't know it's
making me mad all right
so let's talk about this now you
probably know something about this tom
because this was like a pretty famous
internet
motorcycle thing that happened in
manhattan in new york city in 2013. oh
the hollywood the hollywood stunts yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay
i can add my own angle on all this okay
from my motorcycle experience all right
um yeah
you know about this know about how to
beat that dude's ass
you should not beat that dude how to
beat that dude's ass i [ __ ] saw how
it happened i watched the whole [ __ ]
video that'd be just asked
now um would it have been legal no of
course not
no no but i still wouldn't be his ass go
ahead go ahead
tell a story so september 29th
why i had to beat his ass i watched how
he was driving i saw what he was doing
and i also understand chinese culture
in chinese culture if you own a car you
are superior to a person who owns what
they call a motorcycle
and what they call a motorcycle is
anything with two wheels
and in china what they're talking about
is a is a motor scooter
they look down on people who have motor
scooters
as poor people
there was a [ __ ] group of dudes
[ __ ] running in a big old event that
they had promoted online and they wanted
to do stunts on the street
and this guy was acting up and trying to
get in the way of the event it was like
a parade
a parade on the freeway they're trying
to record each other doing stunts on the
freeway and everything
and he caught their attention and he was
doing power breaking on him and uh
to he was flexing that he had an suv
to his girlfriend
which meant that he was a higher class
than these guys on two wheels most of
these guys on two rows were black
it was it was a mixed crowd of black and
white
they [ __ ] this dude up
and i saw the whole thing
and uh was it wrong yeah it was wrong
but i still would have done it i do all
kinds of [ __ ] that's wrong i would have
[ __ ] that dude up
but go ahead go ahead
well hopefully i don't care that it's
wrong i would have [ __ ] him up and
said yeah this shit's wrong i'm gonna
[ __ ] you up more because you're making
me do something that's wrong always
blame the victim always always
tom of course
[Laughter]
y'all need to sober up a little bit
you're saying some stupid [ __ ] right
it's not stupid is it yeah it is
i saw the video stupid dude is an
[ __ ] he needed his ass beat everybody
in this situation everyone in this
situation thank you
thank you everyone this was not a
situation of good version and again this
is kind of a situation where yeah why
why dudes are idiots i'm sorry dudes are
idiots it was why did they do this
versus evil [ __ ] situations they will
get into like they will go to prison for
the stupidest [ __ ] [ __ ] but that's
the way it was that's the way it was
they were mad they got very mad at this
dude go ahead and tell a story jenny
they have like no go ahead and tell the
story they have no [ __ ] uh conception
of like
this of like normal like consequences or
anything like that it's like they don't
give a [ __ ] about any of that happened
in a mad max style [ __ ] situation
between men on the road yeah doing their
thing and they started fighting on the
road dudes are stupid and
hey thank you hey
i will tell you this in that motorcycle
event i'm not gonna call them a gang
because they didn't hang out regularly
it was it wasn't a gang it was just like
that that they threw
in that event who did this [ __ ] were
black gangsters who didn't even have a
[ __ ] motorcycle license and white
cops in the same [ __ ] gang beating
this chinese dude's ass for the way he
was driving i mean like i said it wasn't
a gang in the sense that a lot of people
didn't really know each other but yeah
some of them were off-duty cops they got
in trouble for that later yeah
and
uh a man
knows when another man needs his ass
beat and and we know that the law has
nothing to do with it really the law has
no say in when another man
needs his ass beat it's a [ __ ] thing
of honor
a man's instincts tell him when it's
time to beat another man's ass to keep
that [ __ ] in check and then those man's
instincts also get him into prison
that's because other men
did that
it has nothing to do with right and
wrong other men did that okay and those
are [ __ ] men that did that to him those
men are lesser status or it could be
they are of lesser state if you do dumb
[ __ ] then your actions come back and
bite you in the ass right back and forth
on you by [ __ ] men who couldn't have
done what real men did
using laws on paper that some [ __ ]
might want to write but then they use
other real men in uniform to enforce
this on other real men who weren't in
uniform it doesn't everybody
not do this
not
make everybody just not do this stupid
[ __ ] if you're a real you may not get a
prisoner don't listen to these
[ __ ] do what you do don't
listen to them don't tell them that
don't listen to them jesus christ just
telling you don't don't tell dudes to
just do whatever they want to do you
know how that goes
don't tell that that's the way it's been
going for thousands of years yeah and we
don't like that the scorpion we don't
like that this is back and look i'm a
girl and [ __ ] this is the way i'm a
girl
knock it off it will be that way forever
not if we kill you all no it won't
happen
this is a temporary situation that is
falling apart and it goes back to
bro-ness eventually it goes back to bro
it'll go back to bro
it's going back it is return it is
returning to brohamness as we speak
it's just it is the cycle this is it is
the cycle of heat of life
um
but it's it's okay are you gonna sing
the lion king song now i'm gonna sing a
lion king song but it's okay you don't
know how that's i'm happy with not
watching
but it i'm happy with the way that it's
going because i know you are it's just
because you are a crazy person no i'm
not crazy tila says always blame the
victim tom is from another planet
no no no no no no yeah he is yeah thank
you thank you thank you you're he's from
another planet thank you he's not from
here that's for sure not from this
planet no you're not i'm just telling
you what it is yeah the [ __ ]
[ __ ] with tom's the only one that knows
how things are and you have to listen to
him because he's the only one that's
right
in the whole entire history listen to
this story you will understand if you
were a man
go ahead
it's a man thing go ahead tell them the
story of the tell them how this goes why
should the video used to be on youtube
from beginning
to the end of yeah
and i was like yeah that dude needs his
ass beat
the average person
watching how this happened
that dude needed his ass beat
it just did cops agreed and gangsters
agreed they were in the motorcycle
[ __ ]
crowd he just needed his ass beat that's
all tila said no doesn't i mean dude
look look look look look
it doesn't have anything to do let me
talk no i'm just saying look i said he
just needed his asby i didn't say he
needed to be killed his wife didn't need
to be [ __ ] [ __ ] up yeah well that
gotta have too yes
someone tried to pull her out of the car
and said you're gonna get it too yeah
but it didn't yeah
okay well it didn't really it didn't
happen yeah well you know how that would
have gone if they could have got her out
of jail
if they could have got her out of the
car and she didn't even do anything they
were very mad
they were very mad i would have been mad
i'm sorry but that's no excuse excuses
have nothing to do with it only ability
has something to do with it they could
do it so they did it
it did yeah that's really not the way to
run [ __ ] sorry that's the way the rich
people do it
you're not rich they aren't either
you know but they did it and there are
consequences and don't cry about the
[ __ ] comments no no no no you gotta
you go to [ __ ] prison you just then
don't [ __ ] cry about it they come out
of prison though they come out you know
they go to prison they come out of
prison rest of us don't want to live in
the world with y'all
is what we're saying the world happens
the world happens and you yes thank you
i live in it also no one has any choice
it just happens
it just happens you kind of you kind of
act like you're the only person that
knows what the world is like what
happens everybody lives in the same
world as you happens
you know yeah we know i'm just saying
that it happens we're just not i'm not
here to crazy like i'm just not here to
judge it we're normal i understand it
we're normal i understand it so i'm
vibing with it
okay
tila says what's tom drinking i have no
idea uh tequila to be honest tequila
um
yeah tila says notice these are all dumb
ass dudes yeah i did notice that
go ahead and chick off you go ahead and
chick off too it's true you haven't even
heard the story tina you haven't even
heard the story um
i i there's not a single woman involved
in this spoiler alert yeah yeah
so there would never be a woman it's all
dumb ass dude [ __ ] it's all dumb ass
dude
because dudes do the stupidest [ __ ]
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] like and i'm not
saying that women don't do stupid [ __ ]
too though we absolutely do and there's
like even like women road rage [ __ ] like
that happens but there's a reason why
it's like 96
97
men
there's a reason for that there's a
reason why 90
of serial killers are men there's a
reason for that
y'all stupid
you rarely see women on the road well
it's like i said it's just not it's not
worth it women we have too much to lose
you know what i mean it's just kind of
like
this is really not
you know i'm driving in traffic like i
said i've had road rage [ __ ] where i got
really mad
and i wanted to kill a [ __ ] i'm
not saying it doesn't happen i've done
it myself
but
[Music]
you know and i've done dumb [ __ ] too but
it's like after a while you're kind of
like it's not worth it it's like this is
really not like oh a dude cut me off in
traffic it's like is that really worth
like me getting killed or somebody else
getting killed no it's not worth it
that's not what happened though it's
just well that's yeah you missed the
first part of that conversation so
dude was break checking people and
trying to stop the parade uh well can we
add though that the parade yeah uh they
did not have any permits they don't need
permits and they were not
and they were blocking all the traffic
for people trying to get out of the city
so there was that so i can see getting
annoyed by all these [ __ ] people you
know
tom needs to have his own segment the
true way of things yeah it's just kind
of let's turn into podcast rage um
yeah there's stuff that happens look
uh i'm a woman i understand but you guys
are not really that hard to figure out
like all the all the men that men stuff
that happens that only men can
understand like i understand that it's
just i understand it i just think it's
dumb
it's dumb
so all right
here we go
september 29th 2013.
so there's a group of but it's not a
gang i know that that was kind of like a
thing later on it's like oh it's a
motorcycle gang it wasn't a gang it was
just like an event that kind of like
they organized online they didn't really
some of them knew each other but it
wasn't like you know it wasn't like a
gang in the way that you would perceive
it
so they have this like annually
it's a rally and they call it hollywood
stunts now the guy that organized it is
a guy named jamie lau
now
what they would do
is that they wanted to do like they
would try to and like i said they didn't
have permits or anything like that
they would like try to block off streets
going into times square in manhattan
and they would like try to do stunts and
all this other kind of stuff like i said
they didn't have permits so you can see
how people would get kind of like pissed
off because it's like hey i'm actually
like trying to get somewhere or i live
here or whatever and you guys are in the
way look i grew up in daytona beach and
it's like
i'm you know i don't mind bikers and
stuff like that but you guys blocking my
traffic when i have to get someplace i'm
gonna get irritated with you so just you
know i'm just saying
so uh so they have like you know
thousands of people show up
in four wheelers motorcycles dirt bikes
whatever the [ __ ] and they show up and
they try to
i mean they essentially on purpose try
to like block traffic illegally so they
can like do tricks and [ __ ] like that
yeah like antifa and blm
are we really gonna start that oh hell
yes hell yes we're going though like
auntie for blm can i stop the show now
can i please stop the show okay go ahead
go ahead go ahead go ahead go ahead good
good can i please continue
would you want to stop the show
i was gonna stop the show if you're
gonna go that way
it's like that same thing
can i please do my story great good good
please don't make me smack you i really
didn't want to smack you on this show
seriously i still have like two more
cases to do okay i knew this was gonna
happen okay no no sorry
so
i'm gonna say since 2009 you were
actually not allowed to drive through
this area of
broadway in times square because it was
it's been pedestrianized
but like i said the motorcyclists they
kind of like try to take it over they
try to do tricks blah blah
now uh
so
the guy that got beat up he wasn't the
only person that complained there were
actually other 200 other people that
complained that day like people blocking
traffic bikers blocking traffic uh you
know and like being in areas where they
weren't supposed to be so there was that
reckless driving yada yada
so
uh the guy that was driving the suv
alexian lean
so he comes across a group of
motorcyclists bikers bikers in lower
manhattan
uh
the guy he was 33 years old then back in
when this happened 2013. he was a banker
a chinese-american and he was going to
uh thank you tila for tom's first smack
go ahead jenny
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
go ahead
well you know
i'm just telling you the way it is
matter of fact i gotta say tom needs his
own segment called tom telling you the
way it is like i said why don't why
don't you do your own segment yeah yeah
i will will we'll put that [ __ ] if i do
my segment why don't you do your own
channel
well i've been trying to i just never to
get around to i've been so busy you have
a business
you just want me to do it and help you
and i'm not going to do it i just don't
really care if you want your own channel
you got to figure it out
i'm not going to do it
if i do my own channel i want to live
stream through that [ __ ] that which
means i'd have to [ __ ] uh do my own
[ __ ] wifi hot spot probably
well you better figure out how to do
that i know how to do it i just [ __ ]
man all that
yeah it's a lot of work isn't it yeah
and he doesn't want to do it yeah i
don't really want to do it i kind of
feel like he wants me to do it i don't
care that much and i'm not going to do
it i don't really care i got enough work
to do i can't do your [ __ ] too you
figure it out
if i get off into it i'll do it we'll
see
okay
i don't think there'd be enough demand i
don't think anybody wants to hear what i
want to say have to say about it
i wouldn't drink on my [ __ ] uh you know
i mean i would [ __ ] actually uh
do some training and stuff i have a
bunch of stuff i could show people
not so much y'all but maybe like other
people
you know
we'll see
i keep waiting how to pack a rock and
[ __ ]
uh call him [ __ ] on a lot of [ __ ]
that i hear
you know on the internet and just no
tila says i love tom right upside his
head
[Laughter]
lots of love to give she says yeah yeah
ain't worried about tea
just send me some more tea so
send more money to you that's all yeah
and tom what's up with the cooking show
see it's the thing don't like i never
say anything about anything i never you
have no
anything that he says on the show no
he's not going to do it i never said he
don't think about a cooking show he's
not going to do it
when i mentioned a cooking show i said
well the lighting has to be [ __ ] just
right to do cookie show because [ __ ]
food looks like [ __ ]
under in on a camera under normal
lighting it looks it looks terrible
you know i mean you have to have [ __ ]
badass lighting
i'd have to [ __ ] set up a whole
goddamn
studio in the [ __ ] kitchen down there
it's just it's a lot of work and there
wouldn't be yeah imagine that there
wouldn't be a lot there wouldn't be a
lot of payback i imagine that it
wouldn't mean
i wouldn't make much money on it yeah
neither do i you're right
well you know that's what i mean that's
what i'm trying to tell you it's a lot
of work so i kind of feel like
i kind of feel like you you want to do
your own show but i think you want to do
i think you low-key want me to do it no
no i don't care or at least like if i do
my own show it'll be just nothing but
live streaming and i'll be talking about
current events it doesn't really it
really wouldn't take me much to talk
about current events really it'd be easy
but
i don't think there'd be an audience
well there might be but like i said yeah
even if you're just doing that i mean
you still have to do like graphics for
the show you still have to like if you
want to do like an audio podcast you
have to figure that out for the rss feed
nope you have to figure all that out
nope i wouldn't do any of that i'll i
wouldn't have any audi i wouldn't have
any [ __ ]
graphics or any nothing
but just do it [ __ ] super super basic
yeah yeah right you awake or yeah okay
just saying i wouldn't do anything for
the show i'll just live stream and talk
but see like i said if you want to
do it
you really have to like commit to it
like i said it's a lot of work i think
kind of people think that oh you can
just have a youtube show and like you
make money off it
that's not the case you actually have to
put it's like a full-time job pretty
much yeah and i have three of them
full-time jobs
um and this is one of them
so it is like actually a lot of work you
do have to put a lot of work into it and
a lot of the graphics and stuff and i'm
lucky because i can because i can do a
lot of that myself but
you know if you don't know how to do a
lot of that stuff it's like kind of a
pain in the ass
so yeah so the whole thing started with
this hollywood stunt thing
uh the suv which was driven by alexi and
lean he comes across this group of
motorcyclists in lower manhattan
now at the time he had his wife and his
two-year-old daughter in the car they
were actually going to new jersey
because it was him and his wife's
anniversary and they were going
somewhere like celebrate it
now
he actually called 9-1-1 at first
because he saw a bunch of motorcyclists
running a red light
and almost hitting a woman uh with a
baby
now when he called 911 i guess he was
like in between like new york and new
jersey so he got a new jersey 911
dispatcher
and he said to the new jersey person
like look there's a lot of bikers out
here and it's like they're driving
really dangerously they're popping
wheelies they almost hit a woman um
they're kind of like going by cars and
like smacking the tops of cars [ __ ] like
that and they're trying to like block
all the cars
um so he's like i'm just gonna try and
go around them so he like kind of drives
sort of past
now
basically it's kind of like
as i said this wasn't the first time
that this group of bikers had taken over
the section of manhattan the cops were
very familiar with it there were
thousands of them like i said it wasn't
legal they didn't have permits that part
of the um area was pedestrian only
but
they were kind of like known for
blocking off all the traffic so they
could do tricks and [ __ ] like that
um
now his wife did actually she got mad
and she threw
like part of a uh like part of a bottle
of water that she drank out of and like
part of a plum that she'd kind of eat
off but she kind of threw it at him
because she was bad so she did that like
at her window
huh
yeah
bad mistake good
good but
she threw stuff at him yeah remember all
this like i said she was passionate yeah
yeah so she was like throwing something
it came out well because they were
trying to get somewhere and they
couldn't get anywhere because everything
was fine
okay good
and so
uh
so yeah
so she did that
and then one biker
um
came and punched their driver side
mirror which broke it
and then
that other biker was like uh
gesturing to like other bikers like hey
come here and like [ __ ] with this dude
and then like yelling at them and
threatening them and stuff like that um
and screaming profanities at them and
making this gesture right here the
slitting throat gesture
now after this
uh on the henry hudson parkway which is
upper manhattan
uh another motorcyclist named
christopher cruz merges in front of uh
lean and put his brakes on so he break
checked him
and then he quickly slowed down and then
the range rover that lean was driving
kind of like hit the back of the
motorcycle because the guy had stopped
real quick
now
uh in this situation
uh christopher cruz reportedly sustained
minor injuries after being struck by the
suv
so lean stopped all the motorcyclists
stopped
now at this point the video
which is available online if you would
like to watch it it's everywhere
because this is a pretty famous case
video shows a bunch of bikers gathering
around this range rover
and
they all kind of gather around the car
and they start like hitting and kicking
it
so at this point uh lean decides he's
gonna like try to get the [ __ ] out of
there so he puts his foot on the gas and
like speeds up and runs over it and runs
over
uh three motorcycles and a
one guy named edwin uh mises i guess is
how you pronounce his last name
um now he had got off his bike and was
like
checking on christopher cruz i guess
so lean just like kind of just like run
over him
um at this point like lean said that his
wife was just kind of like just go just
go go go like let's get the [ __ ] out of
here so he just went like without really
like worrying about it and he like ran
over a bunch of bikes and a dude
so
um
he he says that he didn't really know
what to do he's like i don't know what
to do it's like it's everything they're
kicking my car and blah blah so he just
like went
and she's like just go
and she's like hey there's a space over
there so he just like made a hard right
because it was like an opening and he
just went that way
and there was that
now mises did
sustain some severe injuries
his back was broken
and he had a punctured lung
now mises later said well i was just
checking on christopher cruz after he
got after the range river hit him
and i was walking back to my bike and
then i got run over so there was that
so like i said everyone's [ __ ] in
this like no one made good decisions in
this situation
now at this point everyone's mad at lean
the guy that was driving the suv because
he had run over
that one guy
so three guys well he ran no he ran over
by the bikes and ran over one guy he ran
over three bikes and one person it
wasn't three dudes you see this it was
three bikes and one person when you see
this [ __ ] on video you'll see it's a
bunch of dudes in a [ __ ]
pissing match really
of who whose dick is bigger than whose
which is why it's dumb and you have a
bunch of guys [ __ ] that lots of them
no one cares how big your dick is so
just calm down a bunch of dudes on
motorcycles from it's a cross section of
humanity white black outlaw and [ __ ]
cops all in this [ __ ] thing
and they're trying to have a party on
the [ __ ] streets doing wheelies and
[ __ ] taking pictures of each other
their grandstanding and stunting and
[ __ ] trying to get attention you got
other guys blocking traffic all this
stuff about well we can't go some
there there's road guards to events like
this where they try to block traffic to
keep the cops out of this [ __ ] flying
circus
of maniacs doing [ __ ] stunts on a
public street is it legal no it's not
legal it's not legal
but they're doing it anyway it's like a
protest
that's why jenny's it's not a protest
though they're not buying this point of
views from a biker they can do that
anywhere from a biker's point of view is
like a protest they could do that [ __ ]
all you cagers you're going to show up
with four wheels [ __ ] all you cages
we're on two wheels that's what they're
doing all right yeah and i get that but
you're not protesting anything like
important we're protesting all you
people in cars
okay and it's it you have to unders you
only
motorcycle mostly you're just getting in
everyone's way is what you're doing only
motorcycles people that have
places to go
so
only
motorcyclists understand it
okay
oh i understand it it's just that you
think it's just that you think the world
revolves around
it and it doesn't motorcyclists taking
over other people in cars also have
we're not worried about the cars [ __ ]
the cars they're they're they're they're
lower echelon than you
okay and then you had chinese guy who
says no i'm in a car i'm higher echelon
than you it was no he just had some
place to go no he didn't i saw the
[ __ ] thing he could have [ __ ]
pulled over i would have also been
irritated he could have pulled over and
let the event pass him
okay and then he could have gotten
behind it he could have i saw it i saw
the whole thing happen
i'm not gonna get mad i'm not gonna get
mad about it i understand it i saw the
event but i mean
the thing about it though is that they
even
act in a fool
yeah i'm not saying but he
did some [ __ ] that he shouldn't have
done too but he ran over that when look
from the beginning when he wrote this
[ __ ]
from the beginning the [ __ ] was illegal
look if i was driving around the city
and i had some place to go like my job
or something like yeah great take that
someplace where people don't actually
have to drive because if i have to go
somewhere and you were in my way then i
am also going to get irrigated they
weren't going slow they weren't going
slow like move they were not going slow
they were going fast like i got you i
get it i'm not gonna run over a
[ __ ] right but i'd be tempted to
they were not going slow they were going
with traffic but they were trying to get
people away from the stunt area
okay that's all it was
you just gotta watch it for yourself
yeah i've seen it all right um i've seen
it but the thing about it is that the
thing i don't like about it from the
beginning is that hey they were just
trying to like hey we're gonna block off
all these streets that are we don't
really have any right to use and just
for attention like [ __ ] off with that
people have to parade people have to use
that area it was for other things it was
an outlaw people have to and like look
the world doesn't revolve around your
toddler asses
so please move
for the adults thank you whatever it's
like it's that so like i get it i'm not
justifying him running over a dude but i
get
how you would be mad enough to do that i
get how you ran out of that dude and
then it became personal okay i get how
you be mad and it was a unifying event
you had [ __ ]
motorcyclists of all [ __ ] stripes
of all [ __ ] ethnic backgrounds
going that dude ran over a guy
you know i mean and they were pissed
okay
they didn't kill him it was it was
they beat him up a little bit but they
didn't kill him okay so
it wasn't as bad as as people are trying
to make it seem
and really
let's look at it this way
this event
added
it added to the biker [ __ ]
gestalt
that it doesn't matter if it's right or
wrong
if you start [ __ ] with those dudes
they'll do something to you and that's
really what it was all about
just don't mess with people
they have small penises and very small
and very fragile egos that's not what it
was yes it is that's what it was it was
just
let's let's be honest about it but what
about the chat what do without the
chinese dude everyone in this has small
penises no stop it and tiny like [ __ ]
like fragile egos this is all about
fragile eating no
that's just that's woman's type that's a
woman's take on it it was more about
trump and that's not legitimate
no she's being i'm people she's being
facetious about it that's not it didn't
have anything it didn't have anything to
do with penises yes it does no it
doesn't yes it does no it does see this
out of this stuff
it didn't have anything to do with
penises
it was just that those [ __ ] got
mad at each other
dude
they got mad
right exactly john's going they did that
the bikers felt like they were under
attack so it was them versus that other
guy
that that's all it was it was she's
trying to read too much into it
when you see the videos it's
it's it's for me it was obvious
what happened
um but no it's it wasn't some
freudian thing about [ __ ] penis size
it was us versus them
type thing
t says it's hilarious t fake
yeah
right exactly no need for me too says it
more about tribalism exactly
it was a tribalistic thing
yeah they're they're they're agreeing
with me it wasn't about penis it's more
like tribalism yeah it's the same thing
it was a [ __ ] it was about tribal
that's the same thing and and it was a
us versus them thing and it's just a
normal part of human psychology
it's
[Music]
motorcycle guys
wanted to stunt and they wanted to
[ __ ] be seen as lords of the street
and they wanted fragile
they wanted to be [ __ ]
captured on [ __ ]
audio visual
on youtube of them going down the street
on a [ __ ] back wheel stunting and uh
being magnificent even though in real
life no one cares no in real life nobody
cares it's not about the observer
it's not about the observer it's about
it's about the [ __ ] participant it's
about these guys doing it you know what
i mean that they are lords of the story
whatever it is that you're doing yeah no
i'm gonna go the rest no okay
but yeah
good luck good job with that
nobody cares but yeah
like i said everyone in this is terrible
so so yeah
so he runs over like i said i'm not
justifying it like i said i'm not
justifying i i i don't feel good about
like all these bikers like if they like
blocked my way to work or like to
starbucks or something like that i'd be
pretty pissed too so just just saying
uh not saying i would have run over one
but
i might have been tempted so i've been
tempted to do that before
somebody get in my way so you know what
i mean i get it
uh so yeah so now they're all like mad
at him because he ran over three bikes
and one person
uh so they start chasing him for several
miles
now during this chase
lean's wife who was in the car their
daughter was also in the kit uh in the
car called 9-1-1 uh four times in an
eight-minute uh time span during this uh
chase
now a couple minutes later uh if you
watch the video um lean stop for a red
light
and then a biker runs up like next to
him
and opens his driver's side door which i
would have locked but you know whatever
um
he opens the driver's side door and then
lean like
steps on the gas again and like drives
the [ __ ] out of there
a couple minutes later suv comes to a
halt and there are other vehicles
there's another red light so there's a
bunch of other cars so he has to stop
again
and at this point uh one of the bikers
gets off the bike
and takes off his helmet and hits the
driver's side window with his uh helmet
and breaks it
and at this point they pull lean out of
his car and start beating the [ __ ] out
of him so he's basically laying on the
ground with a bunch of bikers uh beating
him with their helmets which like i said
again
a bunch of dudes on one
again
[ __ ] so you know they were mad so
hey yeah i get mad yeah and if i did
something bad no one would give me a
break so
just saying tina said this is a case of
lords in my own mind yeah it is it kind
of is it kind of is yeah which knock it
off okay no one gives a [ __ ] about you
no one gives a [ __ ] about your penis no
one gives a [ __ ] about your ego no one
gives a [ __ ] about any of that get the
[ __ ] over don't listen to these women
get the [ __ ] over yourself don't listen
to these get the [ __ ] go back and go
watch them calm down
calm down and get the [ __ ] out of
yourself don't listen to these women go
back and watch the video of the guys
riding and doing their stunts and their
tricks on public roads and and waving at
the camera they were having fun
there there was it was just like a
circus you know and they were just
putting on a [ __ ] show for each other
i don't [ __ ] yeah it's wrong but
to be honest i keep waiting so right
though i kind of feel like the more you
go to like the biker bar and [ __ ] like
that the more i'm like expecting a phone
call that you're gonna be like involved
in something like this and you're going
to prison no actually first of all these
dudes here
cannot really be called bikers they were
cyclists these are these are
motorcyclists
bikers are riding harley's and they're
[ __ ] slightly overweight when they
and they're [ __ ] listen to country
music and listen to [ __ ]
uh [ __ ] uh
[ __ ] free bird and [ __ ] [ __ ]
skinner you know that that's a biker
these were cyclists
they were they were motorcyclists you
know
well maybe some of them listen to
leonard skinner nah
it's all sport bikes
guys on sport bikes so they were just
douche bags on sports bikes
normally you know i wouldn't call them
douche bags they were just dudes on
sport bikes i got a sport bike
they were in new york okay yeah they're
they're new everyone's kind of dude yeah
yeah they're from new york well i don't
know if they were yankees because a lot
of people came there from other people
and yankees are douche bags thank you
you're right you're right you're right
we're gonna blame this on new york these
are all yankee new york douchebags
that's right what's up although some of
them are probably from here no no
they're all from new york thank you
aaron don't listen to these women don't
share this with tom she says that's
right the money
oh i won't
was over there brushing herself you were
brushing yourself pookie did it work
yeah
oh my god you guys if you weren't here
for the first part of the show
she's super into i can't brush my hair
anymore without her
being like hey brush me brush me so i
got her these little
they're like little brushes but they
stick on like a corner of the wall
and kitties can brush themselves and
they have catnip in them and i'm kind of
hoping
she kind of got into that you kind of
got into that right
she was brushing herself just now
yeah go brush yourself
she still wants me to brush her though
she's like it's not the same
you have to do it pookie is brushing
yourself oh my god yeah they're cool i
got them for like 10 bucks there's like
two of them
and
it's like a hairbrush but it doesn't
have a handle so and then you like just
stick it on like a corner of the wall
and it's like
yeah and they can like rub up against it
themselves
so you know
that little girl is so smart she is very
smart yeah like scarily smart she's
smarter than like a lot of people i've
known
for real i'm not even like all right so
good we're doing good how much how much
is left on this show
i don't know about halfway well no we're
more than halfway because there's like
it's the rest of this case and then i
have one more case
which is the uk case which is kenneth
noy which uh several people have asked
me about is that a big case
well the guy i love that case
i've heard of him okay well the guy he
was like infamous before
that happened so we have to get kind of
get into that because there's like a
whole like [ __ ] bank robbery [ __ ] all
right but then he did like a road rage
thing too okay so yeah
so at this point yeah so they pull him
out of the car and they're beating the
crap out of him
uh at this point a
a bystander uh named sergio consuega
intervenes
and he's like putting his hand up being
like uh let it go which you know
seriously
come on
uh so he's like you know knock it off
it's it's over now
now he said at that point like yeah all
the bikers stopped what they were doing
they stopped beating the crap out of the
suv driver
now
at this point though i will note that
one of the bikers did try to pull
lean's wife out of the car like i said
their little girl was in the back too or
their little kid uh tried to pull the
wife out of the car and said you're
gonna get it too or something like that
you're gonna get it too that's what he
said
um but he couldn't pull her out because
of the
uh you know seat belt so you know great
did you know i don't feel good about
that but okay
so uh basically everybody else whose
bystanders were like yeah uh knock that
off just [ __ ] stop
now
at this point uh so
they check on the daughter she's fine
she had like some broken glass on her
from like the window breaking but she
was otherwise unharmed
now lean actually had
lacerations to his sides and his face
and he had to get stitches at a local
hospital
a lot of damage to the suv the driver's
side passenger side rear windows were
smashed one tire was flat and the second
tire was missing so there was that
so the video of the incident went viral
after it was uploaded by one biker uh to
live leak
it was epic had it happened in the 70s
it had been bigger than anything the sex
pistols could have ever come up with
it was epic
but there really was nothing to it
really forgotten now
it just shows you how much it has its
own wikipedia page i found it
people don't really know about it though
i don't know i kind of feel like a lot
of people remember this wasn't that long
ago it was 2013. yeah that wasn't that
long ago they would have made a whole
subculture around this back in the 70s
had this happened in the 70s
we've talked about that well it's like
back then everything was kind of low-fi
yeah i mean
you couldn't find out about stuff now
there's like so much stuff there's so
much stuff that it's like well this is a
big deal but it's like we only remember
for a day or two and then another big
deal this [ __ ] here is [ __ ] bigger
than sonny barger
would have ever done [ __ ] you know it
was kind of like the founder of the
hell's angels type of deal or a guy who
made the hell's angels [ __ ]
famous this is
bigger than anything that they did
in terms of [ __ ] even though the
hell's angels did all kinds of [ __ ]
you'll never hear about it's just
in terms of [ __ ]
in the mass media
this was bigger
um
but the hell's angels did a bunch of
[ __ ]
hell's angels there are hells angels
members that committed all kinds of
[ __ ] crimes and [ __ ]
shootings well you'll never really care
about it honestly one of the ways
because i kind of feel like in the wake
of this happening of this video of this
incident going viral
a lot of uh you know media tried to
paint it as like oh it was a biker gang
and stuff like that but a biker gang is
a very specific thing a biker gang is
basically like
dudes that know each other and usually
not always uh engage in criminal
activity together like well look we're
gonna like cook meth or we're gonna do
this that and the other thing it's
usually drug deal yeah and that's only
common because look it's they're not
really called gangs they're called
motorcycle clubs it's a club yeah and
the clubs are legal
all right and they're not doing anything
wrong
inside those clubs there are some people
that are doing things that are illegal
which would
cause the fbi to call them a gang
um
what they're doing is a lot more intense
than this
but this stands out a lot more because
it was very much in public
but what's weird is that [ __ ] there's
a lot of [ __ ] back in the 60s in which
the biker culture is built on that
wasn't a fraction of this
you know what i mean
not even a fraction of this go back and
watch the wild ones with [ __ ] marlon
brando
that's tame
by today's standards
well a lot of stuff from bad things
well and that's not
that doesn't have anything to do with
what was actually going into the culture
that was just what you saw in the movie
right right and the movies were
bowberries to a large extent so
because they couldn't show a lot of
stuff right that was actually as much as
they might have wanted to
so
they had to imply a lot of things
back then yeah
but that's not to say that [ __ ] like
that wasn't going on back then it's just
they couldn't show it or they'd get in
trouble so there was that
so yeah that's it kind of i don't know
why i just thought of this but i thought
of like the [ __ ] what was that ed
wood movie where they were like uh
where they were shooting porn
oh yeah and they were shooting porn and
it's basically like three ladies in like
one-piece swimsuits yeah like kind of
posing like not i was like wow that's
yeah that's super porny and like they
arrested them
and like i watched on mst and like uh
criminals crew makes the he's like wow
if they're arresting these dudes think
of the arrests they could make at the
beach yeah right
because this was just like bathing suits
that people were wearing but they you
know they were trying to imply
like look we can't show it in a movie
but
[ __ ] than this is going on like i get it
but you know what i mean they there was
a lot of rules they had to like or a lot
of hoops the whole biker [ __ ] thing
is uh
quite i mean they're they're even coming
out with a new [ __ ] um series it's
called uh
the aztecs i think is what it's called
it's gonna it's supposed to be kind of
supposed to be a good biker movie i
think it's called aztecs i thought that
that had been out it's been a
i've been seeing ads for it must be as
new well it's probably a new season
because i kind of feel like we saw
ads for that
uh
two or three years ago like in the
theater
so i think that's a series so it must
just be in like a new year but they do
have some badass [ __ ] bikers all
right but uh the one
but you know me [ __ ] hanging out you
know just
there's also a lot of fakes
you know
um you got guys who
i show up [ __ ] sometimes when they're
like man he's on a crotch racket because
i write a buell you know i got [ __ ]
deals eating on crotch rocket but the
thing is i could [ __ ] that dude up he's
just a [ __ ] fat boy you know what i
mean so most of them are not physically
um
imposing
well you know they have to have some
kind of something to make themselves
feel too superior to other people right
although i'm not saying they're all not
like that they got some bad asses but
what's funny is that
in my experience the guys who are really
badass don't worry about
little things
they're not there for they're there for
business they don't they're like what do
you have what are you selling [ __ ]
how much money can we make on this like
they're they're they're they're
gangsters you know they're not
uh they're not wrapped up in um
what kind of what kind of motorcycle
you're writing or how you're dressed or
they're they're not worried about
superficial [ __ ] they want to know how
much money can be made
well whether or not they can trust you
to be honest [ __ ] like that seems like
if you're worried about [ __ ] like that
that seems to me like you're not
yours like some insecure
that's the way i look because
i mean that's kind of like that in every
subculture if you're worrying about it
then obviously that isn't uh a subject
of insecurity for you yeah because i
don't have a harley i got four bikes but
i don't have a harley
um
i would never buy a harley
i would build a harley but i kind of
feel like that's an old fat dude but
yeah it is
but the thing is i would i would have no
offense i'm just saying it's an old fat
they're good bikes but i would never buy
one i would
not not one that was built i would i
would build one
and my harley would look like a [ __ ]
dirt bike it'd have [ __ ] knobby tires
on it
matte black with rust and [ __ ] it
would look like something from the
apocalypse i'm not into these [ __ ]
full dressers and [ __ ]
thirty thousand dollar [ __ ]
bikes with hard bags and [ __ ] stereo
systems and [ __ ] i mean if i was going
across country yeah i would like that
but that's not what i do with
motorcycles all [ __ ] right from here
to the [ __ ]
bar or whatever yeah i would want
something that's real practical like
something out of the walking dead you
know
you know even though [ __ ]
even though what's his name spike was
the [ __ ] triumph what was his name
uh
what was it what was that character's
name the [ __ ] uh some
the guy [ __ ] the guy that normally
read it no yeah norman reedus what was
norman reedus [ __ ] character's name
in that i can't remember uh
it was merle dixon and daryl dixon
yeah [ __ ] daryl's bike was just a
[ __ ] beat up old [ __ ] triumph
triumph chopper
i would wouldn't mind having like a
harley [ __ ]
chopper with [ __ ] dirt bike [ __ ]
tires on it and
matte black and just real basic you
don't need all that [ __ ]
full dress [ __ ] unless you're going
across country you know
so
but no i you know i like harley's
they're [ __ ] great but they're great
at what they do
but that's not the only bike i could
never have that as my only motorcycle
you know
i like other stuff too
john gore says the nudie cuties that
edward and h.g lewis made were made in
the legal gray zone yeah true uh there
was much harder porn being made then it
was just wasn't for the theaters yeah
honestly um one of my favorite
experiences i actually have a dvd i
don't know where it's at but it's in
this house somewhere
and i have a bunch of
like porn and erotica from the 1930s i
bought it in a like a
store in new york city and i thought it
was like fascinating and it is hardcore
porn it's like there's nuns there's all
kind of like [ __ ] that you would
recognize nowadays it's crude because
it's the 1930s but
you would recognize a lot of the stuff
from uh nowadays and it is hardcore porn
so
there was a lot of that i went to when i
was in new york city in 2009 or 2010
somewhere around there um
in new york city there is the museum of
sex
and when i was there
they had a display of like old like
quote unquote stag films so they had
like it's three floors so one of the
floors was like all old stag films
and they were like showing them they
were projecting them like on the floor
and they had like all these displays
like talking about them and like where
they came from and like i said they
didn't show them in theaters it was they
were privately distributed and it was
like a fat it was fascinating it was
like a fascinating history and like
watching them yeah it's hardcore porn
but you couldn't show that in theaters
there was no outlet for it back then but
they were still making it they were
making it as far back as movies have
been made they just had like some other
outlets for showing it and the funny
thing about it is like ed wood people
like that
they wanted to show some [ __ ] like that
but they couldn't
so they're like we're just going to like
make everything kind of like implication
you know what i mean so it's just like
kind of funny how they look there's a
friend of the show who is a friend of
mine on on um instagram his name is
marcus martin and we [ __ ] share all
kinds of photographs we share
retro porn photos
from the like the 50s and the 60s
sometimes 70s
they're they're not really porn it's
[ __ ] pin-up stuff
beauty goes way back
they had [ __ ] gorgeous
looking at these photographs from the
[ __ ]
40s and 50s and 60s and 70s
it tells you that they had beautiful
women going all the way back thousands
of years ago into the [ __ ] roman era
you know what i mean just
people haven't changed that much you
know
and um
the styles have changed but even some of
those old styles were attractive
um
you know
that's just that that's really all i
want to say about it [ __ ] you know i
mean
you're talking about people trading
[ __ ] porn and this and that that's
still going on now
guys like oh you've seen this one you've
seen it's stripped well it's much easier
yeah yeah
yeah back then you had to have actual
actual films yeah they have the
right but no you now you got guys in
their [ __ ] you know 40s and 50s going
have you seen her and you know it's some
old defunct dead stripper from the
[ __ ] 50s and you go oh yeah yeah
she's great she's great i mean that's
always been going right yeah that's
always been going right
and and uh not the sound [ __ ] ultra
sexist i mean you know i'm in the
[ __ ] muscle scene [ __ ] working out
and [ __ ]
guys trading photographs of [ __ ] old
bodybuilders from back in the day
well how do you get that big oh he looks
good you know i mean [ __ ] that was
without [ __ ] any steroids you know
it's just you know the human body the
human body is a a
potential source of [ __ ] you know
beauty and
how did he excellence that how'd she do
that wow you know
it's just you know i don't think too
much about that i just like some beauty
i just like
the artistry of the photography yeah and
the form it's the eye i don't really
care about like oh what you know
steroids did they take you so i don't
care i'm a man i'm just science you know
what i mean how did that happen look i'm
into science too but i don't like give a
[ __ ] about that i just care about like
the [ __ ] photograph is it a good
image is it an artistic image is it like
a hot image isn't it that well it's not
even that yeah exactly but not only that
i'm talking about who is that person
when were they born what did they do
how'd that happen what their parents
look like what type of [ __ ] you know
what are we talking about here you know
you know that's that's
me and other i guess you could say
collectors of [ __ ] ancient beauty
we're trying to figure out how it
happened you know what i mean how did
this happen let me go to the restroom
tila says jen there's an erotic museum
in miami too i think there might be
um the one in new york is actually quite
cool like i said it's been a while what
what is she
doing oh she woke up she was good she
was falling asleep back there she fell
asleep she has like her little pile of
toys over there she was like toys
with all she's like oh all my toys are
surrounding me
it's okay we're not she's like why why
you guys like [ __ ]
okay
um yeah john gore says muscle mags were
fat material for gays back in the 50s
yeah exactly exactly
uh no need for me too says love pinups
and art of that nature i do too i like
the whole i like that whole like pin-up
aesthetic
um i don't know i'm just like really
into that
honestly if there's an erotic museum in
miami i might have to like drive down
there and like visit it the one in new
york i actually had a really good time
like i said it was it was a long time
ago but it's three floors
and
i remember them having
uh the thing about stag films was i
think like a limited time kind of thing
but they had like
stuff about like john holmes they had
like all kind of stuff it was like it
was fascinating actually
um but yeah so it was it was super fun i
i would definitely go back it's just
called museum of sex
so
if you're ever in new york like check it
out rick shaw says i couldn't imagine
watching porn in a theater that would be
kind of weird wouldn't it i kind of feel
like that would be weird
i kind of feel like porn is more
that's a more like let's watch that at
home that's let's watch that at home
like
there's a reason like only like weird
dudes and raincoats would like go see
that [ __ ] in the theater
you don't want to like publicly watch
like a look until people watch porn okay
it's like i watch porn it's just kind of
like you don't really want to do that
like in front of other people it's what
i'm saying
so yeah where was i okay
um
so i said about oh the suv okay so like
all the damage that the suv had so as i
said the video of this incident as most
people probably know like went super
viral
and
after that there was all this stuff
about oh it was a gang blah blah blah
but that's kind of like not now
after this went viral somebody else
posted a video
from
the same event
but earlier like from 2011
and that event showed the bikers being
[ __ ] like running red lights like
they were kicking cars [ __ ] like that
um
just kind of trying to show hey this is
kind of like a whole thing
now they did find out later on
that some of the bikers were off-duty
nypd
police officers
um
so
yeah no not you
shut the [ __ ] up not you
she knows what's up she's [ __ ] funny
she knows what's up
me and you tila we know yeah but yeah so
uh five nypd officers uh kind of got in
trouble for this
so
uh at least two like saw the assault
that happened so a few of them did get
in trouble
now
like i said there was a whole thing
about like the biker gang thing but
we've already kind of talked about that
it's like it wasn't really a gang so
blah
now
so when it goes to trial because it did
now the lawyer for
uh the guy that got run over
he says
um
that the guy that got run over he didn't
do anything wrong which maybe he didn't
like he just seemed like he was checking
on somebody else and got run over like i
said i'm not disputing that
all he did was get off his bike get over
and try to calm every everybody down
um
her argument was well
lean the guy that was driving the suv
he should have honked his horn or told
the bikers to get out of the way
to
let him get out of there because he was
just trying to get out of there which i
agree he should have done that
instead of just being like holy [ __ ] i
kind of feel like he just panicked and
wasn't really thinking about it he's
like i gotta get out of here blah blah
and he just like ran over you without
really thinking about it now
uh
i don't know if this is true or not but
the guy that got run over um a few
months after the accident he said that
the doctors gave him less than one
percent chance of walking again
um and he said that he wasn't
threatening
when he was hit which like i said
probably true i think he was just like
doing what he was doing did he walk
again um i don't know actually
um this is a while back
um i will say though that the guy that
got run over at the time that he was uh
hit
was actually not supposed to be driving
his license had been revoked yeah a lot
of these cause some of these guys didn't
even have motorcycle license
so let's say that like like i said it
wasn't a gang but let's not like pretend
that they were like a lot of them did
have criminal records and a lot of them
actually were not legally elected yeah
yeah but i'm gonna go ahead and [ __ ]
satan jenny's [ __ ] look looking down
her nose at that
a lot of the guys that didn't have
licenses were also black guys this was
then the well anybody that has a revoked
license
they shouldn't be driving and i don't
care what race you are and here's the
funny thing is that the white guys in
this same group that were riding were
cops
a lot of them were cops yeah yeah
because motorcycles transcends that [ __ ]
they didn't care
it was about
and the guy that got run over
had also been arrested
uh in tooth in may of 2013 for driving
on a revoked license so he was still
like doing that [ __ ] i'm not saying he
deserved to get run over obviously
nobody does well i can think of a few
people to do but
he didn't
uh but he did have a revoked license
just saying
so out of this uh melee
15 people arrested 55 motorcycles
confiscated 69 summons issued in
connection with this event
11 bikers ended up getting convicted
um now
they didn't really pursue a lot of
charges against the suv driver
um
he did actually file a notice of claim
against the city of new york for the
because some of the people involved in
the attack were off duty police officers
so he was trying to like get some
[ __ ] satisfaction there
um
2018 they were gonna do a civil suit but
as far as i know that has not occurred
as of yet
christopher cruz the guy who originally
was kind of like bumped by the suv
initially
um he actually got arraigned in
manhattan charges of reckless driving
and criminal imprisonment because he was
the one that like pulled the dude out
like you know and allegedly also tried
to pull the wife out
he actually pleaded guilty to
second-degree assault and riot he got
sentenced to four months in jail five
months probation
uh another guy at the scene reggie
chance he was the one who broke lean's
window with his helmet
he actually turned himself in
and he pleaded guilty to felony assault
and criminal mischief and he got two
years in prison and three years post
release supervision which i guess is
slightly less than probation
uh robert sims who was from brooklyn he
was in the video uh he was the guy that
was trying to open the suv's driver's
door
he also turned himself in so at least
they did that
uh he also uh was the one that tried to
pull lean's wife out of the car
him and another guy who
was an undercover cop
named uh
he has a polish name and i'm sure i'm
going to pronounce this wrong
uh wojciech braskoff
hopefully that's sort of correct
uh they got tried together
and they
opted out of a jury trial they just
wanted a judge to decide it
um so sims uh got convicted of attempted
gang assault second degree assault
coercion riot criminal possession of a
weapon you got three and a half years
um
and the off-duty undercover police
officer who tried to make it seem like
oh i was just going along with stuff
because i'm undercover and i don't want
to blow my cupboard
nice try um but okay
uh he got initially charged with assault
gang assault riot and criminal mischief
um
[Music]
but he
was charged with assault because he was
part of the larger group that was kind
of like uh
you know charged with the attack and
though he was directly involved
and he was actually
got captured on video wearing a black
vest that said frontline soldiers so if
you've seen the video like you know who
i was talking about yeah
yeah and he was actually punching and
kicking the suv yeah
um so yeah
so he said that i was doing that just to
keep my cover i didn't want to like blew
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ]
um and he's like well i was gonna try
and like stop it but i'd have my badging
gun so i couldn't do anything that was
another like argument that he gave
because okay
um you know
uh so he got convicted of second-degree
assault
coercion right criminal mischief uh he
got acquitted of first degree gang
assault
uh but he got one year on the assault
conviction one year for coercion
uh and he got them
those charges ran concurrently
he also got one year criminal mischief
for breaking the suv's window yeah so
that's all he got pretty much
uh
he did get fired from the nypd but from
that but you know
it's like you're like
like you would yeah
i kind of feel like in some places you
could do this as a cop and you wouldn't
get [ __ ] yeah right you probably
should be fired i mean come on yeah you
should depending on what you do
dependent
there are a bunch of other defendants
but a lot of them got plea deals so it's
again not worth mentioning
so
i don't know man at this point it's just
kind of like
this kind of brought up a lot of stuff
like look should we
make them get perfect because i kind of
feel like they didn't have permits
but
nobody really did anything about them
not having permits they just kind of
like let it happen
even though technically
they weren't really allowed to be doing
that but everyone was just kind of like
oh well they just do it every year we're
just like letting them do it
but
when this when problems arose
now they're kind of thinking maybe we
should like make them get permits if
it's over 50 people
you know
which i don't know that doesn't seem
unreasonable to me that doesn't seem
unreasonable
i'm not going to say anything because
like i said there was another
part of the thrill of those events is
that they were outlaw events
that was part of the thrill why they
were doing it is they didn't have
permission
is that it they were supposed to be out
there doing this damn parade with all
these stunts do you know who else gets
excited about doing things they're not
supposed to do toddlers yeah well yeah
of course nobody says anything it's not
toddlers of course there's toddlers of
course
of course
i'm i'm not i'm not going to talk about
it anymore
i mean there was another there was this
event but then there was also this other
older lady
who like an older lady she was 78
in december of 2013
and she actually got hit
uh by a motorcycle who was doing the
same kind of thing they were like in a
pack and they were doing stunts and
stuff she got hit
and her
and the driver of the motorcycle got
both got killed
in the accident
he was doing some [ __ ] where he jumped
up on the seat
and he was like pulled up the front
wheel and he was going like super fast
like he was standing on the seat like
that and then
he hit an old lady
and he killed her and he killed himself
what was this
what where was this in new york city
yeah well there you go well and like i
said that was another thing that like
made them think hey we need like like
string like stricter permits on this
kind of [ __ ] because
they were doing they were doing tricks
in places where they weren't really
supposed to be doing it so
that's kind of thing well because like
the the motorcyclist got killed also and
he not only killed like an old lady that
just lived around there but you know so
there was that another thing that they
were doing is they were riding [ __ ] they
shouldn't have been on the street like
four-wheelers
okay the four-wheelers are off-road
vehicles
and they were they put street tires on
four-wheelers and they were doing
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] on those too
like i said the world doesn't revolve
around y'all so
other people have lives to live
we don't want to like live our lives
around y'all's stupid [ __ ] going on
in the street where we
drive and walk and whatever
it's like you know what i mean go see
who we're talking about you know what i
mean it was looking it was the hood the
hood was happening i would also get
irritated i would also get it half of it
was the hood the other half was [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] white people
it was crazy black people and crazy
white people doing the [ __ ] it was it
what i thought it was [ __ ] hilarious
you know
but that's that's my that's my genetic
makeup
i see [ __ ] like that i just go laugh you
know because you're just a psychopath
yeah
i don't care pretty much
go ahead go ahead on to the next story
all right i'm looking at pookie and
pookie's look at her what's she doing
looking over there
hi sweetie she's got the [ __ ]
her little eyes are like
she's like what i'm just sitting here in
my life
we're on the last case now yeah this is
a british case now this is some this is
a case that a couple people like asked
me about so i kind of wanted to get into
this now we're not getting into the road
rage stuff until the end because this
dude did like a whole bunch of other
[ __ ] like before the front range [ __ ]
happened so
i was gonna say this dude needs this
whole loan show but i don't know if
there's enough there for a whole loan
show but you know we'll do this
so the
incident that we're talking about the
road rage incident happened in may of
1996 but before that
we'll get into this motherfucker's
backstory
so here's this dude named kenneth
noy now
his whole thing was that
er the image that he wanted to portray
rather
i'm one of these like rags to riches
business like i grew up super poor and
now i'm like really really successful
but
he's really really rich and successful
because he's a [ __ ]
criminal essentially
so he's from a place called bexleyheath
in kent
his dad ran a post office his mom
managed a dog racing track he drops out
of school at 15
and he had like a whole bunch of jobs
like going at once he was very very
ambitious
he starts delivering milk delivering
newspapers he's doing like everything he
can do like he works in a store he sells
programs at the dog track he's all all
kind of stuff that's going on
um
but
when he was still a teenager he's like
you know
i think that maybe
i should be a criminal because it seems
like pay better which i get it it does
um
so when he's still a teenager
uh he starts receiving stolen cars
and gets uh a few years in
i think like whatever they're
it's i think it's called a boar stole
right it's like the underage
boys prison whatever so he gets like
sent away to that
now when he's 23 he gets married to this
woman named brenda who
[Music]
was
i one source i read says she was an
engineer's daughter one source i read
said that she was a secretary for
somebody that was at the bore stall that
he was at i don't know which one both of
those could be true i'm not entirely
sure
um
but he starts like training as a printer
in the 1970s he starts working night
shifts on uh fleet street
and then at this point he's like you
know what [ __ ] this working for other
people [ __ ]
um i'm gonna like set up my own business
so he sent up a sets up a haulage
company um in kent
and then he goes into and this is not
legal
exactly so you know he goes into the
building trade and then kind of like
property buying and selling
but like i said not entirely on the up
and up
now he actually also had some investment
quote unquote in a us trailer park which
made him 300 000 pounds somehow
which okay um
but he was still doing some illegal [ __ ]
so 1977
uh he got an 18-month suspended sentence
uh for receiving and possessing like a
firearm
so
his business was still doing good though
so in 1980 he had enough money
to build
a 10 bedroom
mock tudor mansion on 20 acres
and this is uh near west kingstown not
really sure where that is but that's
like a big house right
so
apparently whatever illegal [ __ ] he was
doing was
uh
you know
giving him some dividends
uh he also was able to buy a villa in
northern cyprus
and a yacht which cost 700 000 pounds so
you know
again you can't really do a lot of
illegal hsa
uh now here's his involvement in one of
the most notorious
heists in british history
november 26 1923
six gunmen burst into a warehouse near
london's uh heathrow airport
uh they poured a bunch of gasoline on
the security guards and said we're gonna
set you [ __ ] on fire
um
and then they were pretty much able to
like buy that threat they were able to
get out with a whole bunch of jewels
cash and a bunch of like gold bars all
kind of [ __ ] they got away with all kind
of stuff it was like the biggest heist
in british history
uh
nowadays this is known as the brinks
matt
uh
you know heist
now they stole a bunch of
stuff but they always
this is hilarious they stole a bunch of
gold bars 6
800 gold bars
now they stole this
um
i kind of feel like they thought that
all the money that whoever the you know
uh person was that told them that all
this money was there
they're like we thought that it was
going to be in cash so when it was in
gold bars
they didn't know exactly what they were
going to do with almost 7 000 gold bars
right so they're just kind of like
okay so we have these like now what do
we do
um because
six thousand eight hundred gold bars
that weighs three tons
so
there was that
um
they also stole a bunch of like platinum
diamonds travelers checks blah blah blah
like almost 27
000 pounds 27 million pounds rather
worth of stuff
now
uh apparently
noy and one of his
compatriots like figured out well we
need to like melt these gold bars down
obviously because we can't like keep
them the way they are
so he started melting some of them down
and i think he even like melted some of
them down and like put them into like
other like copper coins like he was like
trying to mix it together so like it
wouldn't be noticed as much because like
they weren't real
savvy about like what to do with gold
bars
so they did actually
melt down most of the gold bars and
managed to sell most of them
now
the following february there was a guy
who was uh the security guard at the
police who was actually he wasn't a mole
necessarily but he knew about was gonna
happen
um and he was the one that had let them
in so he got caught and then he got
sentenced to six years
so after he got caught they start
closing in on the actual people that
pulled off the robbery so december 1984
they find two of the guys that were in
the gang
and they got convicted and they got 25
years uh there was another guy that they
caught but he got off for whatever
reason
now at this point they're looking for
kenneth noy
now the year that year
uh he actually flew to jersey
the isle of jersey uh with a bag that
had 50 000 pounds in it that was all in
50 pound notes
um and he also
bought
uh 11 gold bars from a bank
and then he took them away in a bag and
put them in a safe
so in january of 1985
a guy from scotland yard a detective
from there who was looking into this
whole brinks mat robbery
he actually got stabbed to death
on the grounds of noyes house
because they were watching kenneth noy
because they suspected that he had
something to do with the robbery
but i guess they didn't have enough
evidence to convict him so they were
just like watching him
so at this point like kenneth noy
straight up
stabs the dude to death on the grounds
of his house
and he gets away with it because he says
i didn't know you [ __ ] were out there
watching me and i thought like it was
like a [ __ ] robber or something like
that and so i [ __ ] stabbed him and he
stabbed him and killed him so he got
away with it he killed the cop
and he got away with it because he said
it was like self-defense
this was in 1985.
um he did get charged with murder but
like i said he got away with it
because he said it was self-defense
now
um so that happened
so then he's back in court in
1986
and
uh at this point they're kind of like
okay we're pretty sure that we can
connect him to this big like brinksma
robbery
so the trial lasts 11 weeks
and he
at the end of it gets convicted um of at
least like conspiring to handle gold
from that particular they didn't say
he's necessarily involved in it but they
said well he knew about it and he like
handled some of the gold that like came
out of it so blah blah
um
so they convicted him of that
when they convicted him his quote was to
the jury i hope you all die of cancer he
said what to the jury
you missed all that
so he goes to prison for this for being
involved in this brinksman robbery which
was like 27 million pounds
so they let him out
in 1994.
now he managed to like keep on the dl
for two years
but it couldn't last could it because
apparently not
um
in 1996
he came into the
spotlight again
because what ended up happening was that
he's driving on the m25
motorway
uh
and he apparently gets involved in some
kind of altercation
which is with another motorist the 21
year old
stephen cameron
now
i'm not sure i don't think they know
like who started the [ __ ] because like i
said a lot of times no one videotapes
the first start of like oh somebody
flicked me off or somebody did this or
that the other or somebody cut me off
nobody like thinks to
tape that because no one's taping it
people only tape [ __ ] later on so nobody
like really knows who started it
um
but
apparently what happened was
there was some kind of altercation that
happened between him when he was driving
on m25 and this other guy stephen
cameron who was driving on the m25 at
the same time
and
whatever happened
uh it ended up both the car stopped
steven cameron apparently got out and
like started like
beating on
on kenneth noy and noy
stabbed him and killed him with a knife
uh because apparently he just couldn't
take it that he got his like ass beat by
somebody much younger than him i don't
know what that was all about
so after this happens kenneth noy flees
the
country uh and the police start looking
everywhere for him
1998
which was two years later
they found him he was in spain
um and what ended up happening was that
the woman that had been with
uh
stephen cameron at the time his
girlfriend at the time who was only 17 i
mean he was only 21 uh and she was 17.
and she had seen the whole thing happen
because she was in the car now
they so the police kind of approached
her and she was kind of like her name's
danielle cable and she's kind of like
yeah i'll testify which was pretty
ballsy because we'll find out why later
so she saw the whole thing
now they flew her out privately
um you know said i wouldn't know about
it and she came to the to spain and like
said yeah that's him
and identified him
now
the cops told her look um you can
testify against him at open court if you
want to but please keep in mind
that one other witness to the incident
uh was shot and killed in his car by
someone they're not really sure who i
don't think it's solved
but
she uh stepped up she's like yeah i'm
gonna testify so she did so good for her
um so she stepped up and testified yeah
that's a dude
and
um he pleaded self-defense but the jury
didn't buy it
and he got found guilty this time got
convicted of murder given a life
sentence now the girlfriend that
testified had to be given a whole new
identity because they weren't sure
because kenneth noy because he'd been
involved in this big like bank robbery
and was kind of like a lifelong criminal
so they didn't know like if he knew
because this other witness
turned up shot dead in his car
so they were kind of worried about her
uh because you know he had uh even if he
was imprisoned he had contacts on the
outside
so
they gave her a whole
you know the whole like witness
protection
uh deal
uh they said yes like she's [ __ ]
awesome that she came out and like
you know gave like i said she saw her
boyfriend her fiance like murdered in
front of her so
and she like stepped up and said yeah
i'm gonna identify him in open court um
but you know they had to put her in the
witness protection protection program
after that
um so there was that so he did actually
get convicted in is serving at a life
sentence and good riddance i have to say
because he sounds like a piece of [ __ ]
just saying so
you're just going to like eat taffy yeah
me trafficking all this [ __ ]
not really i mean if i'm gonna eat candy
i'd rather eat something good
[Laughter]
she's acting like taffy isn't good
well it's not
i'm not saying it's not good i'm just
saying that if i'm gonna eat candy if
i'm gonna like eat that many calories
i'd rather have something i like
a lot
and taffy is like not really it's okay
but it's not really something i like it
like a couple days back i went on amazon
and bought a five pound
bag of taffy
it's only 20 bucks
man it's just good
i love taffy that's the same five pound
bag i bought you for like your birthday
or christmas a couple years ago i love
taffy i know you do yeah no one's saying
you can't love taffy i'm just saying
it's not my favorite thing if i'm gonna
have all those calories i would rather
have something i really really really
really like
and taffy is fine but i don't really
really really really like it you know
what i'm saying yeah so
tila's asking you what flavor it is
uh all flavors well it's a variety but
what flavor is that one
uh last one i had was tastes like
strawberry
this one is uh it's blue
blue flavor it's blue flavor blue flavor
i don't know what flavors hold on once
it has everything even root beer flavor
yeah that was a good bag i remember
there were like some good i liked the
didn't they have like a vanilla flavor
the licorice can vanilla can eat it i
don't like to have like peanut butter
flavor yeah the peanut butter was good
the vanilla was good the peanut butter
was good the mint the peppermint was
good yeah peppermint pepperoni was good
they had um
a [ __ ] uh orange and cream which is
yeah that was pretty good the orange and
cream
watermelon flavor
watermelon was okay
like i said i don't mind
fruity candies it's just not my favorite
so it's like if i'm gonna
they had chocolate
vanilla i didn't love the chocolate yeah
it was good
i liked it i didn't love the chocolate
honestly the peppermint ones were my
favorite batman was good
i think you gave me all the peppermint
ones out of the bag because you don't
like those as much they're they're my
least favorite peppermint well see
peppermint's my most favorite yeah i
will eat peppermint anything pretty much
peppermint's delicious that one there
is uh watermelon
green with pink in the middle
tila says peanut butter i'd be devouring
that oh yeah yeah the peanut butter ones
are actually really good yeah
caramel caramel and cream you had those
you can get it you can get it on amazon
yeah it's like i got it yeah i got it
like a few years back like for your
birthday or christmas or something like
that and it's really good i can't
remember what the company is called but
yeah they make it's a really good like
variety it just shows up oh [ __ ]
i got it back there in the man cave
every now and then i'll go and grab a
handful of them and bring them out
they're
peppermint
got that in there cinnamon
i wasn't a fan of the cinnamon ones
they're all good i like actual cinnamon
but i don't like cinnamon flavored
things
it's not exactly the same but the
peppermint ones were
were bomb that was my favorite
peppermints are really good some of them
are just white vanilla
that's good too yeah but honestly
remember okay so you remember like
tootsie rolls yeah which are gross
but remember i like those two how they
have those other tootsie rolls that are
like flavors that are actually kind of
good vanilla yeah like the vanilla ones
and like the orange ones and
strawberries like those are good like
actual
like what okay that's what the [ __ ] it's
just taffy what the [ __ ] flavor yeah
is the chocolatey
it's chocolate chocolate is it yeah it's
it's it's like fudge
it's fudge taffy
it's not like any fudge i ever eat sorry
well
it's retro tootsie roll it's old flavor
but like the ones like the vanilla ones
are amazing yeah like because sometimes
they have those around halloween and
those are really good but like the
tootsie roll like the quote unquote
chocolate ones yeah [ __ ] that
they got flavored ones those are gross
they're good but the vanilla ones are
good
the other flavor ones are good
lemon taffy yeah there you go i don't do
they have lemon in there uh no not now
not in that batch okay yeah tila says i
love some peanut brittle damn now i want
you yeah that's good oh man i haven't
had peanut butter in a long time goddamn
i love peanut brittle yeah that's old
school i like old school
tea what peanut butter is good too i
like peanut butter tea i like classic
candy
old school candy excuse me
you having problems
[ __ ] getting ready to blow up
are you gonna blow up right here on the
show yeah ooh everybody stay tuned he
might explode
i like classic candy you know
uh [ __ ]
taffy
i like uh [ __ ] peanut brittle like
you said i like i like bread
bitter honeys remember bitter honey i
like those too all the old old man candy
i [ __ ] love but the thing is i was
eating old man candy when i was a little
kid i could tear up or there's a
werther's original yeah those are
delicious
and the [ __ ]
butter rum
life savers yeah [ __ ] butterscotch
pieces of butter yeah butterscotch yeah
like some of the old people candy i
don't i can't i can't hang with but a
lot of it was like butterscotch and [ __ ]
like that yeah i'm all about that when i
was a kid don't hate growing up in
southern california it was a lot of
mexican candy that could i can remember
the little [ __ ] um
the little green
white and red umbrella suckers those are
good
uh
the [ __ ] salted prunes
candy that mexicans would eat i eat that
too
the little [ __ ] dried shrimp
just anything you get from the mexican
store
because did you get stoplight candy yeah
i don't know what stop like candy what
is that it's kind of like those dots
that were on the
remember yeah yeah yeah yeah it's kind
of like dots on
yeah yeah they had all that
yeah
he obviously i was talking to cod about
old old-school mexican candy and he
could barely remember those and him he
and i are the same age and but they had
those in mexico too yeah just whatever
they had in mexico back in the early 70s
they had it in southern california also
we had some of that stuff to you in
florida did that in florida they had it
yeah
so we were eating that
it's just like said go to the store and
get mexican candy we'd also get [ __ ]
jolly ranchers the sticks
they had all those sticks all the
flavors fire stick
watermelon sticks peach lemon
watermelon watermelon
everything we had all those and the
little [ __ ] squares
the mexican stuff and then we had stuff
like toffee fae that was we were gonna
be fancy gonna be a fancy high class
gonna be a toffee fake that [ __ ] there
was good it was a little funny they
still sell that they still sell it it's
a little [ __ ] semi-circle of caramel
with nougat a [ __ ] almond in it and a
dollop of [ __ ]
dark chocolate on top of it we got some
of those like before we went to the
movies like a few months ago
out like cbs
and they're delicious they're still good
the one that i'm [ __ ] still looking
for
was one back in the head in the 70s it's
called a reggie bar remember reggie
i don't think i remember that what was
in it
a reggie bar was it was [ __ ] after a
baseball player i think he was a dodgers
and i remember he was a black dude who
was a [ __ ] baseball baseball player i
remember his full name it was called a
reggie bar and it was a round patty of
[ __ ]
caramel
with um
i think
i i think it i think it had
i think it had uh some kind of nuts what
do you call those things uh not almonds
pecans
with with
chocolate poured over them so it was
like a turtle
okay but we called it a reggie bar and
they don't make them anymore as far as i
know thank you janet what did janet say
twenty dollars thank you janet drinks on
me thank you oh my goodness
we don't need anymore but okay does
anybody don't
make reggie bars
because i'm looking for i kind of feel
like we haven't
i mean we'll look online because there's
a lot of like old school candy stores
nowadays because a lot of people are
like nostalgic about that it may have
had it may have had rice krispies in it
but that would have been a hundred
thousand dollar bar
so yeah so that was the one it had it
had i i think
it had pecans in it
i think i mean that does sound good
that's like a turn rice krispies and
pecans thing well turtle's like a turtle
turtles didn't have rice krispies and
then
no
yeah turtles was just like nuts with
like chocolate boarded like in a turtle
somebody's saying no not anymore
reggie jackson that's what his name was
that's right yeah reggie jackson right i
knew that sounded familiar tina's saying
now i have one of butterfingers yeah
butterfingers ooh butterfingers are good
what about chips our good frozen what
about a chicko stick which is a
butterfinger's kinda without the okay i
remember though
but that's when i was really crazy on
those things they were cheap as [ __ ]
they come in taylor said snickers is my
favorite yeah yeah yeah well that's hard
and honestly like well stickers has
everything yeah and snickers if they're
frozen
are
perfection
milky way is better frozen than it is
[ __ ] soft i like milky ways
honestly a lot of candy bars are better
frozen i kind of feel like a lot like
snickers milky way like [ __ ]
peppermint patty yeah i was just gonna
say
really good frozen yeah and even like
the girl scout cookies like the mint
girl scout
that [ __ ] it's way better
i was just reading an article today
about somebody making the argument
that
cold cake
was better than room temperature cake
i'm like [ __ ] you're not gonna get any
argument here obviously well we've
agreed cold and frozen cake is way
better frozen cookies are better than
and frozen cookies are better yeah i
mean honestly even the cookies that we
get from dollar general yeah they're
better frozen so we're talking about
yeah yeah
they're i don't know it's just i don't
it's just better it's just better
i don't know why it's just it's just
true
baby ruth is my favorite yeah baby roots
are good too honestly
snickers can be a meal sure take five
bars this sounds really good oh take
fives are good too take fives i think
are the ones i've got those a couple
times
now are those do they have pretzels in
them too
i kind of feel like they also have
pretzels like they have nuts and
crispies they have like everything in
there yeah but maybe i'm thinking it's
something else
but i've had them a couple times but
yeah they're good also reggie jackson
bar yeah richie jackson with us in
forever i don't think they'd make those
things it was a turtle basically
as a turtle if i remember correctly
but they still have they still have
[ __ ] toffee fake
yeah you can still get those
at walgreens on cbs i've seen them yeah
they're like on the bottom
shelf right but we bought them for
mookies before those are they're
delicious yeah i was eating that [ __ ]
the [ __ ] amc theater goes these are
exactly the same yeah yeah you know used
to sell those things in a [ __ ] box
that big there's like [ __ ] 20 of them
in there
now it's kind of like well it's like a
long thing there's like how many of them
are in there about six there's like six
of them in a long thing
yeah they're still good though
um twix yeah twix are also yeah
that that's everywhere though
uh sarah hidley says bueno is really
good they're hazelnut and chocolate i've
seen those
and honestly hazelnut is one of my
favorite things so
i think i've had those before yeah
not sure if i not sure i freeze my
special cake to last longer do like
eating them fresh out of the freezer
like that and then john gore said ice
cream cake was my fave as a kid yeah me
too
honestly i was kind of like i was all
into ice cream cake and i loved
marble cake
you know what i mean like when you
marble like the vanilla and the
chocolate together and it was always
better
i don't know man like pies i kind of
feel like pie is better when it's like
warm
but with cold ice cream on it but cake
is better when it's cold yeah i feel
like yeah it holds together better the
flavors are better i don't know maybe
i'm crazy but okay so if you guys have
any questions now it's time to answer
ask the questions that we can get off
into that if not we're going to go ahead
and we're going to shut it down
yeah because we're kind of hungry are
you hungry yeah i make something to eat
too what are you going to make um you
want some peanut butter jelly no
that's all i have
that's all you have yeah
um i can do it on toast
what what were you talking about
i don't know like
something not sweet
and come up with some
fudgy the whale before chucky rats gave
him like a fudge
i remember that that was like [ __ ]
carvel like the ice cream cakes
how about uh
grilled cheese sandwich
i can do
that kind of sounds good oh i have stuff
for tacos
taco sounds good i just don't really
want anything sweet and i kind of feel
like peanut butter jelly is like sweet
okay all right i'll come up like they're
good sometimes but that's like kind of
sweet i have
stuff for ramen ramens i don't have any
meat to put in the ramen i don't care
about meat do you have any eggs yeah got
all kind of eggs i like ramen with eggs
with eggs yeah that sounds good you do
that
tila says tom and jen i'll see y'all in
about two weeks going on vacay coming
back
i'm sure she would warn us if she was
coming here yeah
were you coming here no
leave somewhere we won't see her oh
well you have a good vacation yeah you
have a good vacation one of these days
i'll have a big i don't want to take a
vacation in summer i'm going to like
winter time
but it's nice out but yeah go ahead and
shut down jim all right we'll do that
we're going to go have some ramen yeah
hopefully the show wasn't too off the
rails yeah uh but it probably was
whatever
that's just kind of what everyone's kind
of expecting at this point
so
everybody have a good
rest of your evening have a good
tomorrow we'll be back friday night for
the side track show when you talk about
whatever the hell we want to talk about
uh so thanks for dropping by and we will
see you guys on friday evening